SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WILL BEGIN WILL CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER SKINNER I'M HERE THEY'RE
MORE LOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE.
SOME VOTE ONLY ITEMS
[inaudible]
I'M.
ON OUR AGENDA LIST IS ITEM FIVE
TWO TWO FIVE BUT IT'S ISSUES ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX AND
SEVEN AND I WOULD LOVE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE GREAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE.
THOSE ITEMS AND CENTER SKINNER
[inaudible]
HI.
CENTER MORE LOCK [inaudible]
SENATOR BELL [inaudible]
RIGHT EXCELLENT.
THEN WE WILL BEGIN OUR FIRST
DISCUSSION ITEM.
THESE DISCUSSION ARMS ARE ALL
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THIS FIRST THAT WE'RE DOING.
AND THE FIRST -- ONE IS WELL
BASICALLY WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AIR ONCE INTO DO
YOU KIND OF AN OVERVIEW.
OVER ISSUES EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN
GET INTO DEEP IT'S AN ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN ALSO SELF.
I BELIEVE IT WORKS ONCE IT WAS
GONNA BE PRESENTING [inaudible]
RIGHT -- X. ONCE ONCE AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CDC OURS OFFICE OF
FISCAL SERVICES.
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
THE FIRST ISSUE IS RELATED TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
REQUEST FOR FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
TWELVE AND A HALF POSITIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ONE POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IN ONGOING.
RELATED TO RESOURCES BECAUSE WE
ARE FOR SEE AN INCREASE IN
PAROLE HEARINGS.
AS PART OF NOT PART OF THE B. C.
P. BUT AS PART OF THE POPULATION
PROCESS.
ALSO REQUESTING TO ADJUST THE
RATES WE PROVIDE ATTORNEYS WHO
REPRESENTS INMATES AT THE
HEARINGS. FOR THE FIRST AGENDA
ITEM I IF WE COULD.
BRING UP BUT JENNIFER SCHAEFER
WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARING
SIXTEEN GET INTO GREATER DETAIL
BUT THE THE AGENDA DOES HE DO A
GOOD JOB TALKING ABOUT THE MANY
COMPONENTS.
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
I'M LET BEFORE.
AN YOU BEGIN JENNIFER I WOULD
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR.
WHAT THESE ITEMS ARE I HAVE ONE
BCP IN FRONT OF ME WHICH IS THE?
HE TO ADD.
THE TWO NEW MISSIONERS AND ALSO
TO ADD BOTH SOME PERMANENT AND
TEMPORARY FOLKS DUE TO THE BAND
[inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
PAROLE HEARING.
I DO WE HAVE A SEPARATE
[inaudible]
THE ATTORNEY [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT SO [inaudible]
I'M -- YOU'LL GET INTO THIS BUT
I AND THERE'S ALSO A REQUEST. TO
INCREASE.
PAYMENT THE ATTORNEY.
EVER B. B. C. P. -- DOCUMENTS
THAT I HAVE BEFORE ME.
NO DESCRIPTION THAT [inaudible]
AND NO THE LA -- WE'LL GET INTO
IT.
DELEON COMMENT ON IT -- BUT I
WONDER -- WHAT IS THE?
WHERE'S THE PAPER WORK THAT
WOULD.
GIVE US THE ABILITY YOU IT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
LITTLE MORE THAN THE FULL
PRESENTATION IT'S A YEAH IT'S
IT'S A LITTLE BIT IT'S PART OF
OUR POPULATION PROCESS WHICH WE
YOU KNOW WE FORECAST ARE IN
MAYES PAYMENT OR ATTORNEYS IS
PART OF YOUR POPULATION PROP.
IT'S WITH THAT ASSUMPTION WE
MADE IN OUR POPULATION PROCESS
HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING TO PAY
ATTORNEYS AND WE ASKED FOR AN
INCREASE.
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PROPOSAL
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY THERE IT'S
MENTIONED IN THE POPULATION --
BINDER THAT TO ALL OF YOU GET
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE
MORE INFO TO IN WRITING TO
EXPLAIN IT BETTER.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL -- I WILL
ALLOW YOU TO PRESENT BUT I FIND
IT LACKING.
NOT THAT I CAN REVIEW OTHER THAN
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA TELL ME
PERFECTLY.
WE CAN CERTAINLY NO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT GONNA VOTE TODAY BUT
IT'S STILL A YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SO SO THEN BEFORE YOU
BEGIN.
WHAT?
JUST AS THE UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IT IS PRESENT ON YOUR WHAT CAN
EXPLAIN.
WHY YOU WANT TO EXPAND?
THE NUMBER OF MICHENER'S.
WHY YOU WANT IT NO MISSION
ASSOCIATED WITH OR TROLL
[inaudible]
WHY -- THIS PROCESS THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING WHICH ARE ALSO VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION ABOUT.
FOR REVISION TO STREAMLINING.
THE PAROLE PROCESS BASED ON SOME
OTHER STATES MODEL BUT AGAIN I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT OTHER
STATES THEY ARE BUT THAT'S OKAY
WE'LL JUST.
I'M AND ADDITIONALLY D. I. YOUR
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE PAYMENT
TO THE ATTORNEYS REPRESENTS THE
PEOPLE WHO GO BEFORE THE PAROLE.
IS THAT CORRECT SO IT'S FIVE
COMPONENTS YES.
RIGHT RIGHT THOSE DOWNSIDE TO
THEM IN ORDER BUT I CAN'T YEAH
NOT DETERMINE THAT ORDER BUT I
DO WANT TO MORE MATERIAL.
WE WILL DEFINITELY PROVIDE YOU
WITH OKAY GO AHEAD SO THE
OVERALL ISSUE FACING THE BOARD
IS A 38% INCREASE AND PAROLE
HEARINGS THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
NEED TO BE SCHEDULED BEGINNING
IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY THE REASON OF OR
THAT INCREASE IS MULTI FACETED.
WE HAVE HAD A COMBINATION OF
BOTH LEGISLATION AND LITIGATION
THAT HAS RESULTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN.
INMATES WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR PRO
SUITABILITY HEARING.
I'LL START WITH TIME USE
OFFENDERS YOUTH OFFENDERS --
SENATE BILL A TWO SIXTY ONE AND
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN AWAIT
WHICH EXPANDED THE YOUTH
OFFENDER LAWS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
OLDER WHEN THEY COMMITTED THEIR
CRIMES.
NOW DETERMINEDLY SINCE YOUTH
OFFENDERS WHO COMMITTED THEY'RE
THEY'RE CONTROLLING OFFENSE
WHILE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY SO
TWENTY FIVE OR AN UNDER.
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR POSTED ABILITY
HEARING AFTER SERVING FIFTEEN
TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THOSE LEGISLATIVE MEASURES HAD --
TO DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION.
WE FOUND SECIFICALLY WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWO SIXTY
THE FIRST YOUTH OFFENDER LAW.
THAT DETERMINEDLY SENTENCED
YOUTH OFFENDERS IN PARTICULAR
WERE IN OR NOT -- VERY WELL
SUITED FOR PAROLE -- WE KIND OF
COIN THE PHRASE THAT IT'S REALLY
NOT A GOOD IDEA TO SURPRISE
SOMEBODY WITH THE PROFITABILITY
HEARING.
SO THEY WERE NEVER EXPECTING TO
COME BEFORE THE BOARD THE I'M
NOT BEEN PROGRAMMING AND THEY
DIDN'T REALLY THINK THAT THEY
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY. TO AFFECT
THEIR FUTURE.
AND SO WE WORKED WITH -- THE
LEGISLATURE BACK THEN TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THOSE
FOLKS TO ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN
PROGRAMMING.
I'M PREPARE FOR THEIR
PROFITABILITY HEARINGS AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT HAPPENED WITH
BOTH OF THOSE BILLS IS THAT THEY
GAVE THE BOARD.
AND THE INMATES AND TELL THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO GET
EVERYBODY ON CALENDAR WHO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR HEARING WHEN THOSE
BILLS TOOK A FACT.
SO WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DETERMINEDLY SINCE YOU
THE VENDORS THAT WE NEED TO GET
ON CALENDAR BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE COULD HAVE HANDLED
DIED WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES -- THE WAY THE BOARD
WORK WE HAVE TO HAVE THREE
PERSONS ON A PANEL UNLESS WE
HAVE A BACKLOG IN WHICH CASE WE
CAN USE 2% ANNALS.
THE WAY OUR HEARINGS FLUCTUATE.
WE CAN WE HAVE -- WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF WIGGLE ROOM AS TO
WHEN WE SCHEDULE SOMEBODY FOR
HEARING AS WE TRY TO MANAGE THAT
AS EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE WE
PROBABLY COULD HAVE WITH FIFTEEN
OUR CURRENT FIFTEEN
COMMISSIONERS.
HANDLE THAT WORKLOAD.
HOWEVER WHEN THE IN RAY EDWARDS
DECISION WAS DECIDED AND WE
ENDED UP IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS FOR NONVIOLENT
INDETERMINATE LICENSE IN MAINE.
PRIMARILY NONVIOLENT THIRD
STRIKERS.
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PRO
SUITABILITY HEARING AFTER
THEY'VE SERVE THE FULL TERM OF
THEIR PRIMARY OFFENSE.
AND THAT WAS A CHANGE IN THE LAW
WHEN WE IMPLEMENTED PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN WE THE STATE ONLY
EXTENDED IT TO DETERMINEDLY
SENTENCED OFFENDERS.
THE COURTS CAME BACK AND SAID NO
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
REQUIRES US TO ALSO PROVIDE A
PAROLE -- PROCESS FOR NONVIOLENT
INDETERMINATE LICENSE OFFENDERS.
WE DID OUR PROJECTIONS OF ABOUT --
FOUR THOUSAND NONVIOLENT -- INTO
TERMINALLY SENTENCED OFFENDERS
WHO WERE INCARCERATED AT THE
TIME.
AND WE THOUGHT THAT OUR
PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
ELIGIBLE FOR NEW HEARING FOR
HEARING.
SO WE HAD ABOUT EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
AGAIN THAT WE NEEDED TO GET ON
CALENDAR AND THE REGULATIONS THE
COURTS WERE NOT VERY -- THEY
WERE NOT VERY PATIENT -- WITH
THE IDEA OF HOW QUICKLY WE
SHOULD GET THESE FOLKS ON
CALENDAR AND SO WE'VE BUILT THE
REGULATIONS SO THAT IF THOSE
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN DOWN THE
LONGEST.
I'VE BEEN INCARCERATED LONGEST
WOULD GET HEARINGS FIRST THEY
GET A PRIORITY HEARING -- BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN
THE REMAINDER WOULD HAVE A
HEARING BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT KIND OF PUTTHE
BOARD OVER THE EDGE.
I'M AN ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND
HEARINGS ON TOP OF ALL OF OUR
OTHER HEARINGS -- WAS MORE THAN
WE COULD HANDLE WITH OUR CURRENT
PANELS.
IN ADDITION -- ANYTIME THAT WE
CONDUCT MORE HEARINGS IT
GENERATES MORE FEATURES.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IF
SOMEBODY HAS A RECEIVED A THREE
YEAR DENIAL ONE YEAR.
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO ADVANCE OUR NEXT HEARING DATE
TO A TIME THAT'S EIGHTEEN MONTHS
FROM THEIR LAST HEARING.
SO ANY TIME THAT WE PUT ON MORE
HEARINGS.
A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE RESULT IN A
THREE YEAR DENIAL.
A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
ARE THEN PUT BACK ON CALENDAR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS LATER.
SO THIS IS CAMILLE WOULD HAVE A
FACT THE MORE HEARINGS WE
SCHEDULE THE MORE HEARINGS IT
ENDS UP KIND OF SNOW BY
SNOWBALLING BLACK BETTER.
ON FUTURE YEARS AND SO WE ARE
ESTIMATING THAT THE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
ADD BACK INTO OUR HEARING
CALENDARS RESULT OF ADVANCED
HEARING DATES. TO OUR OWN TO
RESPOND PAY PROCESS AND AS A
RESULT OF PETITIONS THAT INMATES
IN FILE TO ADVANCE OUR NEXT
HEARING DATES -- IS ROUGHLY
ANOTHER TWO THOUSAND SO IT'S
KIND OF THREE EQUAL INCREMENTS.
AND SO FOR US -- THAT'S A LOT
MORE SO WHEN FACED WITH THE THE
IDEA OF DO WE WANT TO EXPAND THE
BOARD BY 40%.
WE ALREADY HAVE FIFTEEN BOARD
MEMBERS AND IT SEEMS IS IT'S THE
BOARD OPERATES WE FIRST LOOKED
TO SEE IF WE CAN DO THINGS MORE
EFFICIENTLY -- WITHIN OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES AND SO WE SAT
DOWN AND WE STARTED REALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW CAN WE DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY IT WAS NOT TO
COME IN FOR WITH A RESOURCE
REQUEST THAT WOULD BE -- PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT -- AN UNPRECEDENTED
THE BOARD TO BE EXPANDED THAT
MUCH IN ONE YEAR.
SO WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING -- WITH
OTHER JURISDICTIONS FOR A HOW
THEY HANDLE THEIR HEARINGS AND
WE FOUND THAT -- STRUCTURE
DECISION MAKING SOUNDED LIKE IT
WAS GOING TO BE A VERY GOOD
OPTION FOR THE STATE.
AND WITH THE USE OF STRUCTURED
DECISION MAKING WE BELIEVE THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY PRODUCE THE SAME
QUALITY DECISIONS.
AND THE HAVE INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE CONSISTENCY
IN OUR DECISION MAKING.
AND ALLOCATE LESS TIME PER
HEARING -- FOR ALL OF OUR
SCHEDULED HEARINGS.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO ADDRESS I
APOLOGIZE I'M GONNA BOUNCE
AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
OF WITH.
IN THE INCREASE IN ATTORNEY'S
FEES THAT WE CAN PAY BOARD
APPOINTED COUNSEL.
ALONG WITH EXPECTATIONS THAT WE
PLAN TO BE PUTTING IN PLACE. TO
GO WITH THAT INCREASE IN FEES WE
THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE QUALITY OF ATTORNEY
REPRESENTATION WHICH CAN ALSO
HAVE A PRETTY DRAMATIC IMPACT ON
OUR HEARING CALENDARS GOING
FORWARD.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMEBODY IS FACING A AT THREE A
MINIMUM THREE YEAR THE NILE.
AND YET THEY CAN THEY CAN
VOLUNTARILY WAIVE THEIR HEARING
FOR A YEAR.
WITH NO FOR ANY REASON.
IF THEY THINK THAT THEY MAY BE
MORE LIKELY TO BE SUITABLE IN
THE VERY SHORT TERM THAN A YEAR
THEY CAN WAIVE THEIR HEARING
FORTY FIVE DAYS IN ADVANCE OF
THAT HEARING.
AND NOT GO FORWARD WITH THEIR
HEARING AND NOT RISK HAVING A A
LINK TO YOUR DELYLAH MARCY'S LAW.
RIGHT NOW OUR FEE SCHEDULE IS
SUCH THAT WE INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
TO GO TO HEARING.
ATTORNEYS GET MORE MONEY IF THEY
ACTUALLY GO TO HEARING.
AND IN TALKING TO IN MAKE
COUNSEL AND INMATES AND ADVOCACY
GROUPS WE KNOW THAT.
BOTH THE MERIT OF AN ATTORNEY --
REPRESENTING THESE INMATES IN
THESE IN THESE HEARINGS IS A
PREPARATION WORK THAT THEY DO
WITH THOSE THAT WITH THE INMATES.
AND SO THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE THE
FEE SCHEDULE IS A LITTLE BIT --
IT INCENTIVIZE IS WE THINK OF
BEHAVIOR THAT WE PROBABLY DON'T
WANT TO INCENTIVIZE -- WE WANT
TO LOOK AT INCREASING THEIR FEES
BUT ALSO RESTRUCTURING HOW WE
PAY.
WE LOOKED AT SEVEN COUNTIES AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SEE
HOW MUCH THEY PAY DEFENSE
COUNSEL -- PER AND OUR AND THEIR
MAXIMUM CAP FOR CASE -- WHEN
DETERRENT WITH LOOKING AT -- HOW
MUCH DO THEY?
HOW MUCH DO THEY PAY --
ATTORNEYS WHEN THEY HAVE TO A
POINT -- CONFLICT COUNSEL.
IN CRIMINAL CASES AND THEY
AVERAGE BETWEEN SIX AND EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN FACT AND THE
ACTUAL AVERAGE COLLEGE EYES IS.
I WANT TO SEE SIX HUNDRED AND
SOME ODD DOLLARS ARE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SOME ODD DOLLARS SO
LESSEN WHAT WE ARE REQUESTING A
TO INCREASE OURS.
I WOULD LOVE TO GIVE YOU A LOT
OF DETAILS AS TO HOW WE'RE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
OR FORTUNATELY I'M NOT SURE
WHICH PUMP.
WE HAVE BEEN SUIT -- FOR IN IN
COURT.
FOR FROM THE LOW FEES THAT WE
PAY IN MAKE COUNCIL IT'S A CASE
CALLED IN RAPE POOL.
AND WHAT THEY'RE ALLEGING IS
THAT TO OUR FEES ARE SO LOW THAT
EDICT PLATES TO INEFFECTIVE
ASSISTANCE ALSO.
AND SO WE ARE IN SELDOM
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
PLAINTIFFS IN THAT CASE AND SO
THOSE ARE PROTECTED -- THEIR
CLASS ABSOLUTELY CONFIDENTIAL
INTEL THESE SETTLEMENT AGO SHE
TIONS ARE FINALIZED AND IT WILL
HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY THE COURT.
SO UP WERE ASKING FOR THE MONEY
AND BASICALLY SAYING THAT -- WE
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
PLAINTIFFS IN THAT CASE.
AND THE COURT TO COME UP WITH A
REASONABLE -- METHODOLOGY FOR
NOT ONLY INCREASING THE FEES BUT
WHAT THE FEE SCHEDULE LOOK BY.
AND ALSO PUTTING IN -- NEW
EXPECTATIONS THAT HOPEFULLY WE
CAN MONITOR AS WELL AS A
TRAINING PROGRAM WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT.
HOW UNCOMFORTABLE AND
POTENTIALLY INAPPROPRIATE IT IS
FOR THE BOARD TO BE TRAINING TO
NOT ONLY HIRE COUNSEL TO
REPRESENT PEOPLE THAT COME
BEFORE THE BOARD?
BUT THEN ALSO TRAIN THEM.
AND VERY THAT SAID IT'S NOT A
VERY GOOD POSITION FOR US TO BE
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
POTENTIALLY CONTRACTING WITH AN
OUTSIDE -- ACADEMIC INSTITUTION
A LAW SCHOOL ONE WHO HAS A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY TRAINING
ATTORNEYS TO REPRESENT LAW
STUDENTS TO REPRESENT PEOPLE
BEFORE THE BOARD.
AND HAVE THEM PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF ADVOCACY TRAINING THAT WOULD
BE KIND OF INAPPROPRIATE FOR US
TO DO.
SO HOW COME WE HOPE WE THINK
THAT'S GOING TO COME TOGETHER
AND REALLY HELP -- ARE HEARING
CALENDAR BUT ALSO IMPROVE THE
PREPARATION INMATES WILL RECEIVE
FOR THEIR THEIR PROFITABILITY
HEARINGS THOSE ARE THE TWO MAIN
COMPONENTS.
A IN ADDITION TO EVEN IF WE
INCREASE OUR CALENDARS USING
STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING MORE
HEARINGS PER PANEL PER DAY.
I'M WE STILL DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO HANDLE THE INFLUX
OF HEARING SO WE'RE ASKING OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND OUR
BOARD BY TWO PERSONS THAT GIVES
US THE CAPACITY TO HANDLE ALL
THOSE SCHEDULED HEARINGS.
WITH THE INCREASED CALENDAR
USING STRUCTURED DECISION MAKING.
THE OTHER RESOURCES THAT WERE
ASKING.
FOR IN ADDITION.
GIVE AN EXAMPLE LAST YEAR WE WE
RECEIVED OVER FORTY THOUSAND
PIECES OF CORRESPONDENCE -- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ALL OF OUR
PAROLE HEARING PROCESS SEES.
AND WE RESPOND TO THOSE TO ALL%
ABOUT CORRESPONDENCE WE ALSO
HAVE TO SEND OUT HEARING NOTICES
UNDER THE LAW.
WE DO THAT ALL ELECTRONICALLY
NOW BUT I STILL HAVE STAFF THAT
HAVE TO ACTUALLY PUT ALL THAT
TOGETHER -- MAIL THEM OUT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WANT THAT MAILED OUT
EMAIL AMOUNT TO THE FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RECEIVE THEM VIA EMAIL.
AND SO ANYTIME WE INCREASE OUR
HEARING THE NUMBER OF HEARINGS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE SCHEDULED.
IT RESULTS IN SOME -- ADDITIONAL
DUTIES FOR OUR ADMINISTRATIVE A
SAID OUR OFFICE ASSISTANCE OUR
OFFICE TECHNICIANS AND OUR
ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM
ANALYSTS SO WE WENT THROUGH AND
WE FOR EACH ONE OF THOSE
CATEGORIES WE TRY TO MAKE THEIR
PROCESSES AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE.
SO THAT WERE NOT REQUESTING A
38% INCREASE WE WERE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH SOME ECONOMIES OF
SCALE AND ACTUALLY -- NOT
REQUEST -- THAT SIGNIFICANT IN
GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS IT'S NOT
THAT SIGNIFICANT OF RESOURCES
FOR US. TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THE LAST PIECE ARE OF TWO PIECES --
WHEN OUR ATTORNEYS WE HAVE NOT
EXPANDED OUR LEGAL STAFF FOR
QUITE SOME TIME?
THEY DO TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK INTERACTING WITH ALL THOSE
IN MAKE COUNCIL SO AS WE
INCREASE HEARINGS WE ALSO
INCREASE.
ATTORNEY CONTACTS OBJECTIONS PRE
HIT PRE HEARING OBJECTIONS
MOTIONS COUNSEL TO THE TO THE
PANELS WE HAVE A LEGAL HOTLINE.
ANYTIME THERE'S A PRO HEARING
GOING ON ANYWHERE IN THE STATE
THE PANEL CAN CALL AND GET LEGAL
ADVICE ON HOW TO HANDLE
SOMETHING.
THEY ALSO DO ALL THE DECISION
REVIEWS ON THE BACK AND THEY
REVIEW ALL THE DECISIONS REFER
THINGS FOR REVIEW BY THE FULL
BOARD.
THEY ALSO PROPAGATOR REGULATIONS
AND THEY ARE THE MAIN LIAISONS
BETWEEN US IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR GRANTS OF PAROLE AND
OTHER DECISIONS THE GOVERNOR
REVIEWS.
AS WELL AS OTHER STATE AGENCIES
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL ATTORNEYS TO HELP US
WITH THE INCREASED WORKLOAD IN
THAT AREA.
THE LAST PIECE SORRY IS A CITY
C. R..
A C. D. C. R. AS REQUESTED
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS AND A
COUPLE I BELIEVE -- THREE A
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
I HAVE TO HANDLE THE INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD ONE OF THE REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT CITIES
YOUR DOES FOR US THEY DO A
MYRIAD OF VERY IMPORTANT THINGS
FOR US BUT ONE THAT THEY DO FOR
US.
WHICH IS THE PERMANENT POSITIONS
WHICH I ASSUME YOU'RE MOST
INTERESTED IN.
ISN'T BASED SUMMARIZE -- BY LAW
ONLY CORRECTIONAL COUNSELING
STAFF HIGH LEVEL COUNSELING
STAFF CAN DETERMINE WHAT
INFORMATION IS CONFIDENTIAL AND
WHAT IS NOT -- IN ORDER TO BE
DISCLOSED IN ADVANCE OF A PRO
HEARING IF THERE'S INFORMATION
IN AN INNER FENDERS CALLED THE
CONFIDENTIAL SECTION OF THEIR
PROFILE OTHER.
CENTRAL FILE.
IF WE'RE GOING TO USE THAT -- IN
OUR HEARING OR AS A REASON FOR
OUR DECISION THE PROCESS
REQUIRES THAT WE GIVE THEM A
SUMMARY OF THAT INFORMATION SO
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO IT.
SO WE ARE ASKING TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF STAFF.
THERE'S VERY FEW OF THEM THAT DO
THIS WE'RE ASKING TO EXPAND THAT
STAFF BY TO SEE SEE ONES.
WHO THEN REPORT TO SEE SEE TO IT
THE BOARD SORRY CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR ONE AND CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR?
THREE I'M WHO WORK IN WHAT WE
CALL A SATELLITE OFFICE OF THE
CLASSIFICATION SERVICES UNIT TO
PROCESS EVERY SINGLE IN ADVANCE
OF EVERY SINGLE HEARING THEY
REVIEW THOSE CONFIDENTIAL
SECTION OF THE CENTRAL FILES.
PROVIDE A SUMMARY AND THAT GETS
TURNED OVER TO ME AND MADE ME A
MAKE COUNCIL AND IT SATISFIES
THAT DUE PROCESS IN ADVANCE OF
EVERY HEARING.
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR THREE
POSITIONS -- TO ACTUAL COUNSELOR
ONES.
AND ONE CORRECTIONAL I'M NOT.
HIS RECORDS ANALYST HER HE THEY
THEY PROCESS ALL THE ALL THE
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE SUBMITTED IN
ADVANCE OF HEARING AND DETERMINE
WHICH HAVE IN CONTAINS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION THAT NEED TO GO TO
THE COUNSELORS.
AND THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES THAT
CAN ACTUALLY.
UPLOAD INFORMATION INTO AN
INMATE SIMPLE FILE THE BOARD --
THOSE RECORDS ARE NOT OURS THE
DEPARTMENT OWNS THEM SO THEY THE
CIRCUIT STAFF HAS ACCESS AND THE
ABILITY TO UPLOAD THOSE FILES
INTO THE CENTRAL FILE WHICH IS
REQUIRED.
SO THOSE ARE THE POSITIONS THAT
WERE REQUESTING IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS
REQUESTING LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS ARM FUNDING FOR
OVERTIME IN LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS THAT THEY WILL NEED.
IN ORDER CARRY OUT ALL THE
DUTIES THAT THEY DO FOR EACH I
HEARING THAT IS SCHEDULED.
THAT COVER ALL FIVE I HOPE.
A YES -- I KNOW LA -- HAS
COMMENTS I ONE I BRING UP A
COUPLE THINGS BEFORE.
WE HEAR FROM EITHER DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE EARLY -- AND THEN.
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL PERSON
THAT WE ASK [inaudible] TWO US
AROUND IN THESE PRO ISSUES HI
KEITH -- WIDELY FROM AND COMMON
LAW WHO -- AS BEEN.
REPRESENT OR HEARING
[inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS. FOR THEIR ROLE.
AND IS ALSO BEEN TRAINING
ATTORNEYS TO REPRESENT.
PEOPLE WHEN THEY GO BEFORE PRO
WHO HAS A LOT OF IT [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
BUT THE ONE IS [inaudible]
BE ON YOU SITE THE A COUPLE OF
THE LEGISLATION AS ADAM IN
ADDITION NOT [inaudible] SEVEN
WHETHER THINGS.
YOU REFERENCE THE YOUTH
OFFENDERS -- NOW.
THE INCREASED NUMBER OF YOU.
WILL HAVE.
EARLIER THAN HAD.
OR PERHAPS.
NOT EVEN EARLIER BUT YOU MIGHT
NOT.
ARE ALL THOSE STATUTORY CHANGES
THOSE.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE.
ARE THEY ALSO IMPACTED BY MORE
SEAT LOTS SOON OTHER WORK.
IS ANYONE.
WHO GOES BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
IN CALIFORNIA?
SUBJECT TO THE CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE.
THEY ARE NOT GRANTED ROLE IN
THAT ROLE HEARING IT IS THREE
YEARS WHERE THEY COME BACK.
QUESTION I'M WELL I KNOW THERE
WAS IRANIAN COULD EXPLAIN THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS NOW EVERY
SINGLE INMATE WHO COMES BEFORE
THE BOARD FOR A REGULAR PATROL
SUITABILITY HEARING WILL GET A
MINIMUM DIALING OF THREE YEARS
UNDER MARCY'S LAW.
MINIMUM NO OKAY BUT IN THAT EVER
BE SHORTENED THERE ARE A REVIEW
PROCESS YEAH.
SO I'M UNDER A SUPREME COURT
DECISION CALLED IN RADIX.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT SAID THAT THAT IMBEDDED IN
MARCY'S LAW ARE TO SAFETY VALVES
OTHERWISE IT WOULD BE AN EX POST
FACTO.
APPLICATION LAW IF YOUR
POTENTIAL INCARCERATION HAS BEEN.
AUTOMATICALLY AUTOMATICALLY
EXTENDED UNLESS THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY GET PEOPLE BACK ON
CALENDAR WITHIN A PARTICULAR
PERIOD OF TIME.
THE OTHERS TO SAFETY VALVES THAT
IN BETTER THAN MARCY'S LAW ONE
IS THE INMATE'S ABILITY TO
PETITION.
THE BOARD TO ADVANCE OUR
PROFITABILITY HEARING THE OTHER
IS -- IN RATE FIX THE COURT SAID
THAT -- THE BOARD ON ITS OWN
MOTIONS RESPONSE THEY CAN
ADVANCE SOMEBODY'S HEARING DATE.
AND WE HAD NOT PRIOR TO IN RE
VIC'S WE HAD NOT DONE THAT WE
DID NOT HAVE A PROCESS FOR
ADVANCING HEARING BATES ON OUR
OWN MOTION.
AND SO WE LOOKED AT ALL THE US
SUPREME COURT CASE LAW BEHIND IN
RADIX OR THAT WAS CITED CONVICTS.
AND THEY TALK A LOT ABOUT PAROLE
HEARING A PROBOARDS -- KIND OF-THEY WERE ASKING OR SUGGESTING
THAT WOULD BE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC IF
PROBOARDS WOULD FOCUS OUR
RESOURCES ON THOSE WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY TO BE FOUND SUITABLE.
SO WHEN WE SAT DOWN AND FIGURED
OUT HOW WOULD WE PUT TOGETHER --
WHAT WE WERE HOPING TO BE AN
OBJECTIVE PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY BE FOUND SUITABLE?
AND THEN REVIEW THOSE FILES ON
OUR OWN MOTION WHAT WE DECIDED
WAS WE WOULD LOOK AT EL ALL
INMATES WHO RECEIVED A LOW OR
MODERATE OVERALL RISK RATING AT
THE LAST HEARING.
AND WHO RECEIVE THE MINIMUM
DIALING OF THREE YEARS AND WHO
HAVE NOT HAD A SERIOUS RULES
VIOLATIONS SINCE HER LAST
HEARING.
RIGHT NOW WE LOOK AT THEM AT
ELEVEN MONTHS AFTER THE LAST
HEARING AND WE IF WE APPROVE
THEM TAKE IT BACK ON CALENDAR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS LATER.
AND SO MAX MAXIMUM RATE CAN I AM.
ELEVEN MONTHS AFTER TO SEE AND
THEN THEY GET ON CALENDAR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER WHICH IS.
IT'S SLIGHTLY UNDER THE THREE
YEARS.
NO ACTUALLY IT'S EIGHTEEN MONTHS
FROM THE LAST HEARING SO BUCKLE
STATES ARE FROM THE LAST HEARING
SO IT'S RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE. ONE
OF THE THINGS IS KIND OF
IMPORTANT WE HAVE HEARD --
CRITICISM -- THAT OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW PROCESS
WON'T GET THEM BACK ON CALENDAR
YEAR AFTER THE LAST HEARING
IMPAIRED MARCY'S LAW THE MINIMUM
THAT EILING WAS A YEAR.
PEOPLE CAN FILE A PETITION TO
ADVANCE AND GET BACK ON CALENDAR
WITHIN A YEAR GRANTED IT'S RARE
IN AS A SUPREME COURT SAID.
I'M THERE ARE VERY FEW THINGS
ARE AMENABLE TO THAT KIND OF
CHANGE -- IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME THEY THE EXAMPLE THEY GAVE
WAS PEARL PLANS OR SOMETHING TO
THAT EFFECT.
WE CAN NO LONGER DIE SOMEBODY
BASED SOLELY ON THE LACK OF
PAROLE PLAN SO THAT IS KIND OF
GONE AWAY AND WE HAVE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE
SO EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE PRO
PLANS IF WE THINK THEY'RE
SUITABLE FOR PAROLE WILL GIVE
THEM A GRANT AND THEY WILL GO TO
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SO.
THOSE KIND OF SHORT TERM FIXES
HAVE KIND OF GONE TO THE WAY
SIDE RIGHT NOW EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THE PEOPLE GET THEIR HEARINGS.
BEGIN THE DEADLINE FOR US TO
GIVE THEM HEARING INTERNALLY IS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FREQUENTLY THEY
GET ON CALENDAR SIXTEEN MONTHS
IT'S BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
IN THEIR LAST HEARING DATE IT'S
A HIGHEST GRANT RATE.
OF ANY ANY GROUP OF VENDORS THAT
COME BEFORE US.
SO WE'VE KEPT THAT PROCESS IN
PLACE AND IT'S IT'S A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CASES IT
GET ADDED EVERY YEAR.
RIGHT SO -- WE OBVIOUSLY.
GOING TO HEAR FROM OTHER PEOPLE
BUT GIVEN THAT THIS IS A BUDGET
HEARING WHEN WE IF I CAN'T --
EXTRAPOLATE SOME OF THIS AND I'M.
DOLLARS [inaudible]
FIRST [inaudible]
OUR IS.
FROM THE DATA I HAVE SEEN.
CORRECT ME.
UR RATE OF APPROVAL.
AT ROLE HEARINGS IS ABOUT 18%.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE ACTUAL NUMBER
I'M THERE'S SOME IS NUMBERS TO
THAT I'M I THINK MOST PEOPLE IF
YOU SAY THAT.
I'M ARE GRANT RATE IS LAST YEAR
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT WAS
ACTUALLY TWENTY TWO POINT 74%
2023% IF YOU WANT AROUND OFF.
BUT MOST PEOPLE WHEN THEY SAY
THAT THEY WOULD WHEN I SAY THAT
THEY THINK THAT AUTOMATICALLY.
MY GOSH MATH 7078% OR DENIED
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'M ONLY 22% OR GRANTED WHAT IS
WHAT HOW WOULD YOU.
CHARACTERIZE THE OTHER SO THE
GRANT RATE RIGHT NOW.
IS THE PERCENTAGE OF SCHEDULED
HEARINGS THAT RESULT IN A GRANT --
SCHEDULED HEARING CAN RESULT IN
A POSTPONEMENT A DENIAL
STIPULATION A CANCELLATION A
CONTINUANCE HER WAIVER IF YOU
TAKE OUT ALL THE ONE IF YOU TAKE
OUT EVERYONE IF YOU ONLY LOOK AT
CASES WHERE A DECISION WAS MADE
SOMEBODY WENT TO A HEARING AND
THEY WERE EITHER GRANTED OR
DENIED.
PAROLE THE GRANT RATES 39%.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT I'D LIKE
BACK UP.
ABSOLUTELY LIKE BACK.
BECAUSE WHEN I BASS THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND IN GIVEN NUMBERS.
MY NUMBERS WERE ALWAYS BY BASED
ON YOUR MATERIALS YES MEAN
EIGHTEEN AND 22% NOW THE REASON
I'M GONNA RAISE THIS AND CLEARLY
WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING NOW IS
THAT.
SOME NUMBER OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
THE SEVENTY ODD THAT AREN'T.
COULD.
COULD END UP BEING RELEASED
WITHIN A YEAR.
MIND WHATEVER BUT IF WE LOOK.
THIS WE JUST LOOK AT MARCY'S LAW.
AND WE SAY ALL RIGHT.
YOU.
IF WE SCHEDULE. FIVE THOUSAND
AND WHAT.
DOES THAT WE WILL BETWEEN -- FOR
TO UPWARDS -- SEVEN THOUSAND
HEARINGS IN THE YEAR.
LET'S SAY WE HELD.
FIVE THOUSAND IN OUR RATE 18%.
RECALCULATE THAT ARE RELATED
REALLY THE LEAST ON THAT IS 18%
AND THAT MEANS FIVE THOUSAND
HEARING. 18% THAT MEANS THERE'S
NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT A MAN.
FORTY ONE HUNDRED DON'T.
THOSE FORTY ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
STILL GO BACK IN OUR SITUATION
AND THEN STILL WOULD HAVE.
OR ANOTHER PRO BOARD I'M GETTING
INTO THIS.
RIGHT NOT AS THE AS A REFLECTION
OF WHETHER.
MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
DIDN'T HAVE RATHER.
SO.
IF THOSE FORTY ONE HALF HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
AFTER WAIT THREE YEARS.
THE COST TO THE STATE IS ONE
POINT TWO BILLION.
AS WELL THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND OF COURSE THERE ARE
SERRATION COST IS A LITTLE LESS
BUT IF WE AND THAT.
WILL COST YOU BROKE PROCESS
[inaudible]
OUT.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY
[inaudible]
NOW.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SOME NUMBER OF
THOSE. FORTY ONE HUNDRED REALLY
SHOULD NOT BE GRANTED PAROLE SO
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NEVER GONNA.
HAVE.
ROLE FOR EVERY PERSON WHO GOES
BEFORE.
BUT IF WE YOUR THAT THERE SOME
HIGHER PERCENT -- ACTUALLY.
UNDER UNDER AGREED UPON
OBJECTIVE CRITERIA.
COULD HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY
EITHER WARN ADEQUATELY PREPARED
OR DIDN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION OR WHO KNOWS WHAT.
THEN THE COST TO US IS WHITE THE
COST TO THE STATE IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT.
I'M AND I JUST RAISE THIS
BECAUSE I THINK AS WE DELIBERATE.
IN ADDITION TO CLEARLY THE LANDS
OF PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE LANDS OF
MAKE -- WERE DOING THINGS.
APPROPRIATELY AND EFFECTIVELY
WERE ALSO MAKING SURE WE'RE
DOING THINGS.
SMARTLY FROM A COST.
WHEN YOU VIEW [inaudible]
I'M.
ANYWAY I JUST WANTED TO RAISE
THAT AND IF WE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ROLE HEARING.
AND WE STILL HAVE A LOW RATE SO
WE GET UP TO SEVEN THOUSAND YEAR
AND LET'S SAY WE EVEN GET 230%
UNDER.
SEVEN THOUSAND WE'RE STILL GOING
TO BE ASKING US.
IN THE ORDER OF ONE POINT FIVE
TWO BILLION -- IT'S REAL.
IT'S VERY RELEVANT TO US IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT INCREASING THE
QUALITY OF ATTORNEY
REPRESENTATION IS OF REALLY
SIGNIFICANT.
A MOVE FORWARD IN IN HELPING
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
WE ALSO -- IN THERE SO I WOULD
LOVE TO AT SOME POINT I WANT TO
GET TOO MUCH OF YOUR HEARING
TIME TODAY BUT WE LOVE TO
EXPLAIN THE ENTIRE HEARING
PROCESS BECAUSE I THINK SOME
PEOPLE -- I THINK THAT EVERYONE
JUST GOES TO HEARING IN THERE
EITHER GRANTED OR DENIED THERE'S
A LOT OF REASONS GOOD REASONS
FOR POSTPONEMENTS.
I'M A LOT OF THEM ARE IN MATE --
GENERATED BUT THIS LAST YEAR
I'LL GIVE YOU ACT.
OUT OF IT YOUR FIFTY TWO WEEKS
IN THE YEAR WE HAD TO BRING DOWN
ONE PANEL.
EVERY WEEK FOR TWENTY SIX WEEKS
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE A
COMMISSIONER AVAILABLE.
AND IT WAS THROUGH NO FOUR OF
BOTH OF THEM THE STATE THE
GOVERNOR I MEAN THEY WERE ALL
THE POSITIONS WERE FILLED.
WE TEST WHEN SOMEBODY RESIGNS IT
TAKES A WHILE TO BRING SOMEBODY
ON BOARD AND GET THEM TRAINED UP
TO SIX SIXTY EIGHT WEEK TRAINING
PROGRAM.
WE HAD -- THREE OUT FOR MEDICAL
REASONS THAT THEY COULD NOT.
HELP OBVIOUSLY AND THEY WERE
UNEXPECTED SO WHEN YOU HAVE
SURGERY AND YOU'RE OUT FOR A
MONTH -- WE HAVE TO BRING DOWN A
MONTH'S WORTH OF HEARINGS SO
WHEN WE ARE ASKING TO EXPAND THE
BOARD BY TWO PERSONS.
WE THINK THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
HANDLE THE HEARING LOW
[inaudible]
WITH. SIXTEEN COMMISSIONERS.
AND USE ONE AS WHAT WE'RE
DESIGNATING FOR LACK OF BETTER
TERM AS A FLOATER. TO THAT
PERSONAL BE ASSIGNED AS A THIRD
PART THIRD PANEL MEMBER.
AND THEN IF SOMEBODY IF I HAVE A
PANEL THAT HAS TO COME DOWN
SOMEWHERE IN THE STATE BECAUSE
OF MEDICAL ISSUES ARE UNEXPECTED
LEAVE.
I CAN USE THAT COMMISSIONER TO
BACK FILL AND NOT LOSE HEARINGS
OR YOUR THAT MANY INMATES EVERY
SINGLE WEEK AND TELL THAT PERSON
COMES BACK ONLINE.
SO I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT METHODOLOGY BEHIND THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT CYCLES
THROUGH THAT CREATES THESE
PROBLEMS IN OUR HEARING CALENDAR
OR EXACERBATES THEM.
ARE THE POSTPONEMENTS ESPECIALLY
IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
HELP.
SO THINGS LIKE IF WE DON'T GIVE
SOMEBODY THE NOTICE OF RIGHTS OR
IF WE'VE DONE SITE THEY HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THE NECESSARY DOCUMENTS
THAT DUE PROCESS REQUIRED THAT
THEY GET.
WHICH IS WHY THE COUNSELORS ARE
SO IMPORTANT THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT SERVE THOSE DOCUMENTS ON
INMATES AND WE SEND THEM TO
THEIR ANSEL IS WELL.
IT'S ALL THERE'S A LOT OF PIECES
TO IT IT AND IT HAS TO ALL WORK
WELL AND EVERYONE HAS TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO DO
WHAT THEY DO.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THOSE
HEARINGS BEFORE IT.
I'M HEARINGS ARE VERY.
I GO TO IT.
ON FRANCIS WITH OTHER PAROLE
RULING AUTHORITIES FROM. THIRTY
THIRTY STATES ARE MORE AND
SEVERAL OTHER COUNTRIES.
I'VE YET TO FIND A SINGLE
JURISDICTION HAS THE HEARINGS
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS THAT WE
DO.
AND THAT -- SPEND AS MUCH TIME
AS WE DO TERMINATING --
PROFITABILITY SO WE'RE HOPING
THE STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING-RULES WILL SHORTEN THE HEARINGS.
AND HAVE THEM FOCUS ON WHAT IS
MOST IMPORTANT.
THE ATTORNEY REPRESENTATION IF
IT IMPROVES WILL HELP WITH BRING
FOR HEARINGS YOU MAY SEE MORE
PEOPLE FOUND SUITABLE IF THEY'RE
PREPPED -- WELL BEFORE -- THERE
IS THERE HEARINGS.
I'M WE JUST DON'T KNOW -- AND OF
COURSE.
I BROUGHT UP.
THE DOLLARS BUT THE OTHER ISSUE
ISIF THERE ARE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THAT.
WHERE SUITABLE WHO ARE NOT?
WONDER OUR CURRENT PROCESS EVEN
A SMALL PERCENT WERE ACTUALLY
FOUND -- THEN WE WHOLE.
NOT ONLY IS IT US WEST.
IT ALSO WERE UNDER ORDER TO OUR
POPULATION AND A CERTAIN NUMBER.
IT THEN END PROCESS AFTER YOU.
MAKE OTHER DECISIONS OR MAKE
OTHER COMBINATIONS THAT.
YOU KNOW IF IT COULD.
AND SHOULD LEAVE BE [inaudible]
BETTER FIX [inaudible]
IN THIS [inaudible]
THIS WENT [inaudible]
PURSES BROUGH.
OTHER WAYS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
GET OUR POPULATION [inaudible]
I'M.
I WOMAN ASKED THE LA -- YOU
[inaudible]
THERE.
WHAT'S ON THESE THINGS WE DID
NOT GET INTO YOUR REQUEST AROUND
THE I. T.. FOR WE ALSO HAVE NOT
YET REALLY DISCUSSED BESIDES
MISSION.
YOU WANT A NUMBER OF NEW F. T.
E..
A NUMBER THAT ARE PERMANENT AND
THE NUMBER THAT ARE SHORT TERM.
AND I GUESS I PERSONALLY WOULD
WANT TO UNDERSTAND BETTER.
LOGIC FOR THE SHORT TERM
[inaudible]
ON LIKE UNDERSTAND THAT BETTER
I'M.
AND THEN FINALLY.
AFTER THE LA -- SPEAK SOMEONE
ASK WHAT LEAD I'M IN A ABLE AS
MY COLLEAGUES OUT.
QUESTION PERFORMANCE.
M. ROLE.
WE'RE HAVING.
PERSONALLY FOR ME BE ABLE.
TO I'M REALLY GET INTO A
DISCUSSION AROUND [inaudible]
BE.
STREAMLINING PROCESS AND BE.
I'M.
STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING
FRAMEWORK.
I WANT TO SEE IT I WANT TO SEE
AND I WANT TO SEE EVALUATIONS OF
IT I WANT TO KNOW WHAT OTHER
STATES HAVE USED LIES IT
[inaudible]
I'M.
I DON'T WANT TO THEY ALREADY
THAT I HAVE ANY PREJUDICE
AGAINST IT BUT I CERTAINLY IS.
ALL.
THE WOMEN ON GIVEN THAT ALL I
HAVE.
IS THE FOUR FIVE THAT IS IN A
DARK.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO KNOW THE SEVEN
STATES WITH SEVEN STATE.
I CAN'T THIS OHIO CONNECTICUT
SOUTH DAKOTA WASHINGTON KENTUCKY
IN UTAH.
I'M IN IT PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
FRAMEWORK OR THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CORRECTIONS HAS
ADOPTED IT AS A BEST PRACTICE
AND SO IT'S BEEN TAILORED FOR
EACH OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS.
ADMITTEDLY THOSE JURISDICTIONS --
DO NOT HAVE A LIBERTY INTEREST
IN PAROLE.
AND SO IN CALIFORNIA I'M OUR DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS ARE MUCH
DIFFERENT -- PAROLEES THAN THEY
ARE IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
THE BEST ANALOGY IS THE NATIONAL
PAROLE BOARD OF CANADA THEY ALSO
HAVE A LIBERTY INTEREST IN
PAROLE THEY DO NINETEEN THOUSAND
HEARINGS A YEAR.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ORIGINALLY SPENT A DECADE --
DEVELOPING THS IN IMPLEMENTING
IT.
AND SO -- IT WE ARE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING A LOT WITH CARLETON
UNIVERSITY WHICH IS THE
UNIVERSITY IN OTTAWA CANADA THAT --
DEVELOPED IT FOR THE PROBATIVE
CANADA AND THAT'S WHERE WE'VE
REALLY BEEN PUTTING OUR EFFORT
IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS IN
CANADA BECAUSE IT'S MORE NOW
AGAINST ANY OTHER STATES TO US.
YOU MENTION A STATE AND I HAD-CANCERS OHIO AN ETIQUETTE.
SOUTH DAKOTA WASHINGTON KENTUCKY
IN UTAH.
AND THEY USE THEM FOR BOTH SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM OFFENDERS
SOME OF THEM JUST SHORT TERM
OFFENDERS SO.
VERY VERY DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS IN DIFFERENT WAYS
OF APPLYING IT.
GREAT -- LA -- WANTED -- TO BY
NOW AND WHAT WE WANT.
TO HEALING O'NEILL WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
I'LL GIVE ARE COMMON ON THE
STRUCTURE.
I'M MORE AND THEN [inaudible]
YOU.
DID YOU NOT HAVE ANY COMMENT ON
THE DECISIONS AND THERE ARE.
BERMAN INNER LIMITED TERM.
WHEN WE REVIEWED THAT BUDGET
REQUEST WE THINK THAT EVER?
YOUR REASONABLE -- HOWEVER HAS
ALSO INDICATED IN MY YOU MAKING
FRAMEWORK.
THE REQUESTED RECORD U. S. M. AT
THE REMARK IS IMPLEMENTED ON
TIME AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
BUDGET YEAR AND IT HAS THE
ANTICIPATED UP BACK ON THE
LENGTH HEARINGS -- IF IT DOESN'T
HAVE THAT EFFECT.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT ARE MEANT
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
IN OTHER WORDS AT EASE REQUESTED
RESOURCES AS SOON.
AS WELL IMPLEMENTATION OF
FRAMEWORK [inaudible]
AND SO.
M..
WE DO THINK THAT THE FRAMEWORK
AS IN KERR'S PROMISING GIVEN IT
IS THE BEST.
YES.
I'M NOT ABLE TO REVIEW THE FRAME
WE HAVE NO WE HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T
IN THE FRAMEWORK.
OF THE RIVER REVIEW LITERATURE
ON THE FRAME WORK ON IT I
FRAMEWORK.
I'M AND TO WE THINK IN GENERAL
MEANS LIKE A PROMISING APPROACH.
I'M BUT IT THE PROPOSAL LACK --
AND WE HAVE BE OUTLINED.
INFORMATION THAT WE THINK -- IT
LACKED IN YOUR IN THE REPORT
WHICH IS REFLECTED IN YOUR
AGENDA BUT AT A HIGH LEVEL.
AND THE KEY INFORMATION.
I IS THAT IS IT WOULD BE
REQUIRED -- EFFECTIVELY EVALUATE
PROPOSAL IS A PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK.
THE TIMELINE HOW WILL BE USED
HOW OLD WILL BE IMPLEMENTED AND
HOW WILL BE EVALUATED.
WE THINK THAT THAT INFORMATION
IS IMPORTANT THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF MENTALLY
THING IF THEY CAN'T CHANGE IN
HOW WE MAKE ROTH.
AND AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THE FUNDING REQUEST [inaudible]
EMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
MARK.
THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LET.
HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
WE WILL HOLD RECOMMENDATION ON
THE MUZZLE AND RECOMMEND
DIRECTING -- DEPARTMENTS PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION IN A PROTOTYPE
ALLEGEDLY REVIEW.
I'M TO THE EXTENT THE DEPARTMENT
IS NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT AND
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO MOVE
FORWARD REGARDLESS.
IN THAT ARE APPROVING RESOURCES
ON A ONE TIME BASIS AND
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT BACK WITH.
THE INFORMATION IN TIME FOR IT
TO BE CONSIDERED IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS.
MOVING ON TO EAT COMPENSATION
FOR IT ERNIE'S APPOINTED BY THE
BOARD.
WE THINK THAT THE NEW PAGE
BERKSHIRE A NEW KEEP A STRUCTURE
DOES APPEAR NEEDED -- BUT AGAIN.
WE FOUND THE SELECT AND KEY
INFORMATION WHICH IS AGAIN
OUTLINED IN YOUR GENDER BUT A
HIGH LEVEL -- WE FOUND THAT IT
DIDN'T HAVE A WE ARE OR
SUFFICIENT -- EXPLANATION OR
JUSTIFICATION IS.
THE BASIS OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR PROPOSED PAYMENT
[inaudible]
I'M.
THE STRUCTURE OF THE NEW AB
EIGHT ABLE A SCHEDULE WAS NOT
PROVIDED WITH THE IMPORTANT
GIVEN THAT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
CURRENT ONE HAS SOME --
POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE.
THAT WE WANT TO AVOID RECREATING.
I'M AND THERE WAS ALSO NOT M. HE
TOLD INFORMATION PROVIDED ON THE
CHANGES.
BORDERS AT ANTICIPATING MAKING
TO ATTORNEY RECRUITMENT TRAINING
AND I AGAIN WE RECOMMEND DIRECT
IN THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION.
I'M IF IT IS UNABLE -- I'M IN
THE NEAR TERM AND ALSO IN LIGHT
OF ENDING IT -- ASIAN LET.
BUT BY.
ONE AND IN OUR DEPARTMENT REPORT
BACK ON THE BEAT.
OUT THERE.
IN TIME FOR NEXT.
STONE THAT YOU MADE THE POINT --
ON THE ATTORNEY A BUT IN I AGREE
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE WITH THE
STRUCTURE WOULD BE.
WORSE YOU HAVE THAT PAYMENT.
OR THAT.
CURRENT FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
YOU.
WHAT'S THE NUMBER OF HOURS
ATTORNEYS ON AVERAGE WOULD SPEND.
WOULD WE EXPECT.
I MEAN THIS IS BUT YOUR FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS JUST HAS THIS
LIKE. TWENTY FIVE BUCKS.
FOR IS THE GREEN TO DO IT AND
SEVENTY FIVE CORRECT.
THERE'S AN IMPORTANT ECONOMY
SCALE THAT GOES ON WE WHEN WE
ASSIGN SOMEBODY WHEN WE APPOINT
COUNSEL.
WE ACCOUNT APPOINT THEM TO
REPRESENT EVERY INMATE WHO'S ON
CALENDAR AT THAT OFFENSE AT THAT
INSTITUTION FOR THE WEEK.
AND SO WHEN YOU GET FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS -- AN INMATE THAT YOU'RE
REPRESENTING SOME MAY WAIVE
THEIR HEARINGS EARLY ON SAME MAY
END UP -- YES BUT THEY DON'T GET
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR IT ON
YOUR NO NO NO YOU ONLY GET.
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE OF IT
IF YOU AROUND YOUR ROLE HEARING
YOU ONLY GET A HUNDRED OF IT IF
YOU [inaudible]
SO.
WE IWILL SAY THAT EVEN GIVEN
OUR CURRENT STRUCTURE.
I'M WE HAVE NOT HAD -- WE HAVE
WAITING LISTS FOR PEOPLE WANT TO
DO THIS WORK.
HOWEVER WERE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE QUALITY.
AND THE EXPECTATIONS AVERAGE
HOURLY RATE.
ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA IS.
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR.
CURRENT RATE WE'RE IN FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH I CAN'T
IMAGINE WE ONLY IN OUR OUR WORK.
BUT THEY DO -- WE HAVE IT SET UP
SO THAT WHEN THEY GO OUT TO THE
INSTITUTION THEYCAN INTERVIEW
ALL OF THEIR INMATES AT THE SAME
TIME YOU KNOW THAT KIND OF THING
OR YOU KNOW OVER A SERIES OF OF
OURS.
SO THERE THERE ARE SOME
ECONOMIES IS.
I I HESITATE BECAUSE AGAIN I'M
NOT.
IT'S A LITTLE UNCLEAR HOW MUCH I
CAN TALK ABOUT WITH THE
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS IN THE
CURRENT LITIGATION.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE WE ENTERED SETTLEMENT
NEGOTIATIONS ARE.
GOING TERMS OF SKIN PRODUCT THAT
LAWSUIT WOULD WE BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE ULTIMATE
SETTLEMENT REQUIRES A CERTAIN
PAYMENT THAT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
THAN WERE ANTICIPATING
[inaudible]
YES.
WHICH IS THAT.
NO THEY'RE NOT ONLY. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS WELL AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT IT WILL BE RECTIFIED
BEFORE THE END OF THE BUDGET
YEAR OR SO WE'RE WORKING AS FAST
AS WE CAN BUT I'M WILL%
DEFINITELY BE IN A MUCH WORSE
PLACE.
LITIGATION WEISS IF WE IF WE
DON'T INCREASE IT TO AT LEAST
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW OR WHAT
WE'RE REQUESTING.
SO IT COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF ITS NOT
APPROVED.
IN THE LITIGATION ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CONTEMPLATED
WHICH OF PERHAPS WILL BE SOUND A
LITTLE BIT MORE -- VISIBLE IF
YOU WILL FOR HIRING ATTORNEYS.
IS THAT -- ONE OF THE CONCEPTS
HAS BEEN PUT OUT THERE IS THAT.
YOU ASSIGN SOMEBODY THERE A
LEVIN CASES FOR THE WEEK OR TEN
CASES FOR THE WEEK.
AND YOU BASICALLY TREAT IT LIKE
A SALARY.
YOU GET SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR EACH OF THESE UNDER STATE
BAR RULES YOU HAVE A LOT OF
OBLIGATIONS IT SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR NO OVERSEEING GOING
FORWARD IF WE DID THE SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS WE COULD
STRUCTURE IT IN A WAY.
WHERE YOU GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THIS IS JUST HOW WE CURRENTLY DO
IT WE'RE LOOKING AT REVAMPING
THE WHOLE THING?
SO THE IDEA WOULD BE INCREASED
TRAINING INCREASE FEES BUT ALSO
A DIFFERENT KIND OF FEE
STRUCTURE SO I WAS JUST
EXPLAINING WHERE THE THINGS IT'S
BEEN -- EXPLORED AS A POTENTIAL
OPTION IS ACTUALLY GIVE THE THE
FULL AMOUNT FOR ACCEPTING THAT
REPRESENTATION.
AND THEN SOME OF THEIR CLIENTS
AREN'T GOING TO NEED THAT MONEY
THAT MANY HOURS AND THEN THEY
COULD USE THAT TIME FOR THE
OTHER CLIENTS TO DO RESEARCH.
YOU NEED MORE HOURS SO THERE
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING
IT THAT WAY WE DON'T INCENTIVIZE
BEHAVIOR.
I'M OTHER THAN PERHAPS WAVING
MAYBE EARLY ON TO AVOID WORK BUT
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S A BAR
ISSUE AND WE WOULD BE WORKING
WITH AN OUTSIDE ENTITY
[inaudible]
FORCED OUT.
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THATWE HAVE
SUBMITTED AS PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS.
AND SO WE'RE STILL DISCUSSING IT
WITH THEM AS WHAT IT WOULD LOOK
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
ADOPT THEM.
OR THE TOTAL MEANT THAT'LL AND
WHATEVER WE ADOPT WE STILL DON'T
HAVE.
WE HAVE A DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR YOU
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A KEY.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW TO
NAVIGATE ALL OF THAT TO BE
HONEST I'M NOT SURE WHY I DON'T.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT ALL I COULD IN
GOOD FAITH.
DISCUSS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
INCOME ARRIVE IT WANT TO ACT.
BY JUNE FIFTEENTH WHAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO INCREASE THE
ATTORNEY'S FEES I AM I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE
SHOULD BE PUT IN THERE THE
SUBJECT TO THE COURT'S APPROVAL.
IN OR SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT
BUT WE DEFINITELY BUT THE RIGORS
OF THE STATE BUDGET PROCESS --
TIMING TIMING WISE IS NOT VERY
CONDUCIVE TO SETTLING LITIGATION
SO.
I'M OPEN TO WHATEVER SUGGESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE FOR
HOW TO STRUCTURE THAT -- BUT I
DON'T WANT -- TO VIOLATE --
ISSUES THAT I HAVE A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT [inaudible]
DOMINIC GLACIATIONS.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT WORKS.
AND WE'RE OBVIOUSLY NOT ACT
[inaudible]
I WIDELY [inaudible]
ANY.
THIS MAY HAVE THAT MIGHT BRING
LIGHT ON OUR THE ENDING OF ME
OPEN IT.
I AM WIDELY I'M THE FOUNDER AND
THANK YOU.
UNCOMMON Là [inaudible]
NONPROFIT.
THAT FOCUSES ON HELPING.
LIFE SENTENCE PEOPLE TO THE WORK
THEY NEED TO DO IN ORDER.
TO COME HOME [inaudible]
I UP.
AT THE TWO MEN.
JENNIFER SCHAEFFER FOR THE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND AND
PROFESSIONALISM THAT BROUGHT FOR
ABOUT [inaudible]
I'VE KNOWN.
ALL THE THANK YOU ALL.
LAST NINETEEN YEARS.
AND SHE'S DONE BY FAR MORE THAN
THE REST [inaudible]
PROCESS RIGHT.
IN.
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S THERE ARE
MANY CHALLENGES I THINK SHE'S
BEEN VERY OPEN ABOUT WHAT A LOT
OF THOSE TOWNS THAT ARE -- SO IT
GIVES US ALL THE OPPORTUNITY
FIND FIND A WAY FORWARD
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
BEEN WORKING WITH PEOPLE.
IN MOST OF THE PRISONS AND THEIR
ROLE PROCESS YOU KNOW WE HONOR
WE TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER A BUT
THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND LIVES.
MY FAR MORE THAN ANY OTHER.
AND THERE ARE THOUSANDS MORE WHO
ARE NOT SERVING LIFE SENTENCES
BUT AS OF SOME OF THE THE RECENT
CHANGES.
SHAPER MENTIONED ARE NOW SUBJECT
TO BOARD REVIEW.
SINCE YOU'RE MAKING PROCESS.
WE HAVE HAD.
BUT OUR IN OUR WORK WE'VE WE'VE
HAD [inaudible] TWO HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN WE WE DO ENJOY A
VERY LOW RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
UNDER.
ONE BUT WHAT WE REALLY FOUND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
IT'S BECOME CLEAR IN IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS OF DOING THIS
WORK.
IS THAT WHERE WE HAVE THE
GREATEST SUCCESS.
WITH OUR CLIENTS.
THE WORK WE'RE DOING IS REALLY
UP.
OFTEN IS HELPING THEM DEAL WITH.
THEIR OWN RESPONSES TO CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA.
AND HOW THAT TRANSLATED AND
THEIR ACTIONS ASSOCIATION --
THAT HARM TO OTHERS AND LANDED
THEM IN PRISON [inaudible]
AND THAT'S A PROCESS THAT TAKES
A LONG TIME REALLY EVEN TO
ESTABLISH A RELATIONSHIP WE NEED
TO WITH OUR CLIENTS. TO DO THAT
WORK FOR THEM.
TO DISCLOSE THIS THIS BELIEVE.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WE HAVE
THE GREATEST SUCCESS?
IN THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND IN
THOSE INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS IN
WHICH IN ADDITION TO OUR MEETING
WITH THEM.
THEY ALSO HAVE SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
THE INSTITUTION THEY CAN GO THE
MAN.
THAT MEANS THEY'RE INVOLVED IN.
OTHER PROGRAMS IN THE
INSTITUTION THAT ARE BUILT ON
SOME TYPE OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
OR SHARED SAFETY CHAIRED HEALING
MODEL -- WHERE THEY CAN PROCESS
THE STUFF IN ADDITION TO THE TWO
HOURS WE SPENT TOGETHER?
COUPLE WEEKS MONTHS.
AND WHERE THOSE THINGS COME
TOGETHER PEOPLE HAVE GREAT --
THOSE TEND TO BE LOWER SECURITY
LEVEL PRISONS FOR A LOT OF
REASONS WE COULD TALK ABOUT --
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT WAY BUT
IT WILL WORK OUT THAT WAY.
BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT AS THE
MAJOR THING AND AND AND ALSO
SEEMS THAT.
OVER THE YEARS THE WAY THE ROLE
MISSIONERS APPROACH HEARINGS.
THAT WORK MATTERS MORE THAN IT
USED.
TO IT USED TO BE.
WE TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT LITIGATION USED TO BE THAT
ROLE FOR FOCUS ON THE PERSON
PRIME.
LANDED IN PRISON.
AND IT REALLY DIDN'T MATTER HOW
MUCH THEY CHANGE THEIR LIVES
WHILE THEY'RE THE BOARD WOULD.
BE.
INCLINED TO DENY PAROLE BASEBALL.
AND THAT PROCESS HAS IMPROVED SO
THAT THE BOARD IS MORE
INTERESTED IN HOW MUCH THE FIRST
CHANGE.
WHO THEY ARE TODAY?
THE SHAPERS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING. TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMISSIONERS TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AD AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO HELP THEM
MOVE THERE AND AND AND THAT HAS
HAS DEALT BUT A BIT -- THAT IS
HELP BRING THE ROLE GRANT RIGHT
WHERE IT IS.
YOU ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE SCHEDULED
HEARINGS THE YOUR RESULT ROLL?
AND IT WAS A VERY.
YOUR WAY ASPECT.
THE ANSWER BETWEEN 1822%.
OF THE SCHEDULED HEARINGS ADULT
IN THE ROOM.
THAT MEANS THAT 78% OF THE ROLE
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE ARE NOT.
RELEASED EACH YEAR.
THERE A LOT OF WAYS TO LOOK AT
WHY THAT IS.
BUT WE REALLY NEED A BREAK DOWN
THE WHY THAT.
BUT IT KNOWLEDGE YES THAT MEANS
WEIRD IF IF.
IF THE EXPECTATION.
IN THE LAWS.
IS THAT PEOPLE WILL NORMALLY BE
BRANDED ROLE WHEN THEY WERE
BROUGHT.
UNLESS PUBLIC SAFETY.
IN THE NATION THEY CANNOT BE
REALLY.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE WITH.
PUBLIC SAFETY EXCEPT IT HAS COME.
TO A SMALL THE RULE I THINK IN
PRACTICE -- BUT WE DO SEE.
ABOUT 20% OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE.
ELIGIBLE ARE BEING GRANT.
WE'VE SEEN OF A FEW OF THE THE
CHANGES IN RESPONSE TO THE
OVERCROWDING.
INTENDED TO IDENTIFY.
GROUPS WITHIN THE POPULATION
THAT COULD SAFELY BE RELEASED --
REVIEWING CASES OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONVICTED OF FOUR SERVINGS
CONTRACTS AT FOR NONVIOLENT.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MEASURES
THAT.
SO THE IDEA WAS THE HERE'S SOME
PEOPLE HO ARE NOT THERE FOR
VIOLENT CRIMES.
WE REVIEW THEM ON THE ROLE
CONSIDERATION PROCESS.
THIS HELPS US ROUTE REDUCE
OVERALL POPULATION.
WELL THERE PROGRAM RATES AROUND.
WE ALSO WE ADDED.
THE ELDERLY PAROLE CONSIDERATION
RECOGNIZING PEOPLE WHO ARE SIXTY
YEARS OLD OR OLDER.
SERVE AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
IN PRISON.
ALL THE THE SIGNS ALL THE
LITERATURE INDICATES THERE MUCH
LOWER RISK RESERVE A ESPECIALLY
VIOLENTLY THAN THAN ANYONE ELSE.
THERE PROGRAM RATES ARE STILL
TWENTY SOME PERCENT [inaudible]
YEAH NUMBER.
THE OTHER PIECE THAT COMES UP I
WAS IN THIS BUDGET TEAM ALSO
ABOUT [inaudible]
ADDING COMMISSIONER [inaudible]
TWO TO ACCOMMODATE THE INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
IT IS IT'S AN APPROACH THAT HAS
BEEN USED [inaudible]
SEVERAL TIMES.
THE FIRST TIME I WAS FAMILIAR
WITH BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT INCREASED.
BUT INCREASING NUMBER MISSION IS.
TO FIND WAYS TO DEAL WITH A
BACKLOG OF HEARINGS [inaudible]
THAT APPROACH.
AS ADDED COMMISSIONERS OVER
YEARS.
BUT IT STILL HAS US AT A POINT
WHERE WE NEED TO FIND OTHER WAYS.
TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS.
AND IF WE'RE IF WE'RE NOW.
WHO?
IN THE 20% RANGE.
OF ROLE ELIGIBLE PEOPLE BEING
ACTUALLY RAN IT.
I'M REALLY EAGER TO FIND OTHER
WAYS TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS SO
I'M I'M ENCOURAGED BY WHAT THE
SHAPERS DESCRIBING [inaudible]
WITH.
THE ATTORNEY APPOINTMENT PROCESS.
THAT I AGREE HE THAT.
IT NEEDS A LOT OF WORK
[inaudible]
IT IS.
IT'S THE MAIN WAY THAT PEOPLE
GET ACCESS TO THE KIND OF OUR
WORK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE WORK WITH MY
TEAM I SAY WE SO.
LISTEN TO THE LAWYERS ABOUT THE
AMOUNT ALSO WORKERS.
ALL THIS OTHER.
LAW STUDENTS WE WORK WITH.
WE ALSO TRAIN -- I DO A LIFER
SQUARE ALL LIFE FOR SCHOOL OR
TRAIN OTHER LAWYERS OF TRAIN
HUNDREDS [inaudible]
ATTORNEYS.
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS. TO DO THIS
WORK.
YOU WORKSHOPS INSIDE THE PRISONS
ALSO.
BUT MOST OF THE WORK IS IT'S
IT'S BASED ON HELPING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND HERE THE KINDS OF
ISSUES THE PRO WAR IS MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT.
HAVE YOU WORKED ON IF NOT LET'S
DO THAT.
LET'S GO FIGURE OUT HOW YOUR
CHILDHOOD IMPACT RISEN WRESTLES
IT.
RESOURCES DON'T EXIST LET'S FIND.
WE'LL SEND SOMEONE FROM OUTSIDE
SOMETIMES WERE SENDING MATERIAL
THE PEOPLE CAN WORK WITH.
I'M AT WORK.
IS THE THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF WHAT WE DO. TO THE WHEN WE
GET TO THE PAROLE HEARING
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE THE WORK
THEMSELVES OUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT.
WHEN I SAY IN THE HEARING VISION
AS A NOT AT ALL INTERESTED IN
WHAT I HAVE?
AND THEY SHOULD BE IT'S NOT MY
HEARING.
IT'S HERE FOR THIS PERSON TO TO
EXPLAIN HOW THEY'VE CHANGED.
BUT IF.
IF THE ATTORNEY IS NOT IN A
POSITION. TO PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF SUPPORT ESPECIALLY EARLY
ENOUGH IN THE PROCESS.
THEN I DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE A
MAJOR IMPROVEMENT IN THE OVERALL
WILL PROCESS A LOT MORE CASE.
BUT I DON'T SEE I DON'T EXPECT A
MAJOR INCREASE IN THE PROGRAM
RATES.
AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT
EVERYBODY'S CONCERN [inaudible]
BUT THAT'S MY CONCERN.
BETTER ROLL OUT NOT JUST BECAUSE
I WANT PEOPLE TO GET OUT OF
PEOPLE SAFELY.
AS I SEE WHAT THEY DO WHEN THEY
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS SO.
THAT'S THAT'S MY INTEREST BUT I
LOOKED AT I LOOKED AT THE BUT IT.
WAS A TALK ABOUT THE INCREASING
MISTER.
I'M OKAY WITH THEM INCREASE THE
NUMBER.
MISSION IS IF IT MEANS.
THAT IT LEADS TO TIMELY FAIR
HEARINGS A BETTER OUT.
I HAD NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE INCREASE IN PAY.
FOR OR THE ATTORNEYS.
AS LONG BEEN NEEDED.
I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
AND IT'S NOT NEARLY ENOUGH.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH AND AS AN
EXPECTATION.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO THIS PART OF
THE PROCESS.
I AM IN [inaudible]
ABOUT THE BE INTERESTED IN
BRINGING IN SOMEONE FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
OF LONG BELIEVED THAT.
THIRD PARTY SHOULD BE INVOLVED
IN THAT PROCESS.
BUT I WOULD I WOULD GO A STEP
FURTHER NOT NOT JUST IN
[inaudible]
PROVIDING. FOR FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
WELL THE WHOLE PROCESS PROBABLY
SHOULD BE RUNNING ROLE.
BY A THIRD PARTY.
DO YOU ACTUALLY.
I AM A LITTLE APPOINTMENT
PROCESS.
INSTEAD OF FOUR FOUR YEAR.
THAT'S ONE THING I THINK I WOULD
RECOMMEND -- BE [inaudible]
BE STUDIED [inaudible]
REDUCE THAT.
YOU KNOW RECOGNIZED GOOD AND BAD.
ANGLES BUT THAT IN
RECOMMENDATION WHETHER SPENT.
A LOT OF REASONS THAT IT DOES IT.
WOULD.
TO I YEAH I AGREE WITH.
DE L. A. O.'S BEST.
VISION MAKING AT CARE POINTED
OUT WE REALLY DON'T HAVE MUCH
INFORMATION [inaudible]
INDEED.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
WHEN.
WITHIN THE LAST FORMER WORLD ARE
HEARING.
ANYTHING IT SOUNDS LIKE.
SURE OKAY.
OUR AUTOMATIC PORT OF YOU TO
GENERATE ANY THOSE KIND OF
THINGS.
OR RISK ASSESSMENT -- IS THAT WE
GET REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT --
WHY IS THAT THAT MAY MAKE IT
MORE LIKE THAT BLACK AND BROWN?
I WILL GET BAD OUT.
SO I'M REALLY EAGER TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT.
THE STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING
MODEL THAT IS BEING ADAPTED
[inaudible] FOR CALIFORNIA'S
PURPOSES WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
YET WE LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THAT IT.
WE CAN HELP THE BOARD IN.
SHAPING OUR PURPOSES.
OR TO BE INVOLVED.
WELL YOU'RE IN ABOUT.
LEAVE SOON SENATOR BILL AT ANY
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
I'LL JUST DO THE JUST A COUPLE
QUICK.
POINTS I WANT TO MAKE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP. ONE IS
ABOUT.
WHAT I THINK ARE SOME?
EASIER MORE OBVIOUS. SIX IS TO
THE PROCESS OTHER WORDS.
OTHER WAYS WE CAN HELP IMPROVE.
ONE HAS TO DO WITH.
PEOPLE FOR WHOM ENGLISH IS NOT
THEIR FIRST BY.
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE?
RATE.
OFTENTIMES LANGUAGES SPANISH
WITH A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER OF THE
LANGUAGE.
I'M ON WORK WITH IT.
ENGLISH.
MANY OF THEM HAVE.
TROUBLE [inaudible]
OR DOES [inaudible]
A SIGN [inaudible]
ROLL HEARING.
THEY ALSO SIGN INTERPRETER FOR
THE MEETING WITH.
ALL OF THIS [inaudible]
ROLL HEARING.
LIKE LOGIC.
INTO THE LANGUAGE.
THEY DON'T TRANSLATE.
THE TRANSCRIPT ROLE HERE.
INTO THE LANGUAGE [inaudible]
SO THAT.
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO
FULLY. FIVE OF THEM THE FEEDBACK
HAVE BEEN FROM THEIR LAST. FOR
THE THINGS YOU NEED TO WORK ON
AND THE BRANCH WITH MAYBE A
HUNDRED MORE PAGES.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IF THERE
WERE SOME.
BUDGET ITEM SOME SOME MACINNES
[inaudible] TO ITALY TRANSLATE
THOSE WITH SORT OF AN EASY FIX
TO HELP PEOPLE BETTER.
THAT'S THAT'S ONE THING ANOTHER
RELATED THING IS ABOUT.
BETTER ASSISTING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
AND MENTAL ILLNESS.
I THINK IF THAT COULD BE HAVING.
SPECIALLY TRAINED ERNIE'S SIGN
OF THOSE DAYS.
IMPROPER ORDER.
I DIDN'T COMPLICATED. TO MAKE
SURE THE PEOPLE I'M A DATA.
BOTH IN PREPARING FOR THE
HEARING.
DISSIPATE IN HEARING.
END IN MAKING -- POST RELEASED.
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK BE
[inaudible]
ROUTE.
AND THEN THE THE LAST THING
ACTUAL RELATES TO THE WE TALKED
ABOUT WITH THE ROLE OF THE
ATTORNEYS IN THE BECAUSE I'LL
I'LL I ALWAYS SAY THAT I'M I'M
MORE BUT I'M STILL.
LAWYER. TO WORK IT OUT.
I ALSO LOOK FOR PEOPLE IN A
RECRUITING STUDENTS OTHER
ERNIE'S.
I LOOK FOR PEOPLE WITH SOME KIND
OF COUNSELING THEIR BACKGROUND
OR SOMETHING LIKE.
MOST LAWYERS NOT AN OUT
[inaudible]
THE SPORT.
AND WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT.
RATHER THAN EXPECTING LAWYERS
COMPARE.
OR EXPECTING THEM TO SPEND WEEKS
OR MONTHS -- DOING.
COUNSELING.
THAT THERE BE SOME EFFORT ON THE
PART OF THE STATE.
NOT MISTER THE BORDER ROLE HERE.
WITHIN THE TO PROVIDE SOCIAL
WORKERS -- I CALLED THIS. TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
PEOPLE BE FIGURE THEMSELVES OUT
AND GET READY.
FOR RELEASE ON PAROLE.
AND AND I'M REALLY FOCUSING ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT.
EARLY DIAGNOSE WITH THE AXIS ONE
DIAGNOSIS THAN MIGHT OTHERWISE
BE UNKNOWN A SLOW.
FROM PROCESS SYSTEM.
SUPPORT THEM AND THEIR NEEDS.
ALMOST NONE OF WHICH FOCUSED ON
PREPARING THEM IT WAS SORT OF
ALRP DRAMA AND EXPLAIN THEIR
THEIR OWN TRANSFORMATION. TO THE
ROLE.
SO THOSE ARE COUPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS I HAVE.
BEEN WORK IN THIS AREA FOR QUITE
AWHILE IN A HUNDRED TO HEARING.
QUESTION YOU HAVE THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
THERE ARE CERTAIN RE ENTRY
FACILITIES.
OKAY WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT.
QUESTIONS BUT I HAVE I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE YOUR OKAY.
WHEN I CAN PLANE WHAT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY OF INMATE THAT WE
AUTOMATICALLY A BRAND?
OR MAYBE HOW THEIR RIGHTS SO
REENTRY FACILITIES MY MY
FUNDAMENTAL UNDERSTANDING OF
THEM IS THEY IDENTIFY EVERYONE
WHO'S GOING TO BE RELEASED
WITHIN A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
AND THEN THEY MOVE THEM TO A RE
ENTRY FACILITY.
BEFORE THEY GET ACTUALLY
RELEASED RELEASED SO IT'S KIND
OF A STEP DOWN PROGRAM IF YOU
WILL INTO THE COMMUNITY. FOR
LIFE CURRENT OR THE DETERMINEDLY
SENTENCES BUT BEFORE THEY EVEN
GO BEFORE PAROLE BOARD.
YEAH THE FOLKS TO COME BEFORE
THE PROBOARDS DON'T GO TO THE RE
ENTRY FACILITIES BECAUSE I IN
THE TRADITIONAL THAT KIND OF RE
ENTRY FACILITY BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW.
WHICH ONES THE GOVERNOR IS GOING
TO UPHOLD AND WHICH ONES -- YOUR
SHE MAY CHOOSE TO REVERSE OR
SENT BACK TO THE BOARD FOR A
FULL REVIEW.
SO.
YOU'LL HAVE THE HEARING THE
DECISION IS A PROPOSED DECISION
FOR UP TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYSWHILE.
THE TRANSCRIPT GETS MADE IT GETS
REVIEWED FOR ANY LEGAL ISSUES
AND GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY --
NOTICE OF PUBLIC IN ADVANCE OF A
PUBLIC BOARD MEETING.
IF IT NEEDS IF THERE'S SOMETHING
AN ISSUE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
ONCE IT BECOMES FINAL THEN THE
GOVERNOR HAS THIRTY DAYS TO ACT
ON IT. ONE SET THIRTY DAYS IS
OVER IF THAT IF THAT -- IF I
GRAN IS UP HELD THE INMATES
RELEASED WITHIN ABOUT A WEEK.%
SO THERE'S NO SET IME PERIOD
YOU KNOW YOU WOULDN'T PUT
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY
GENERALLY SPEAKING WHO'S A LIFE
TERM IN MAY. TWO AS A GRANT
PENDING IF YOU MAY HAVE TO BRING
THEM BACK TO STATE PRISON
BECAUSE THE DECISION IS NOT
GOING TO BE FINAL.
OUR IS NOT GOING TO BE UPHELD SO
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF
POPULATION IF YOU WILL SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT FOLKS FOR PURPOSES OF
PAROLE.
I'M AND THEIR PRO PLANS WE'RE
NOT CONTEMPLATING A TRADITIONAL
RE ENTRY FACILITY LIKE THAT
INSTEAD THE DIVISION OF ADULT --
PRO OPERATIONS AND DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THEY
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE
TRANSITIONAL BEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND SO THESE FOLKS WE'VE NEVER
HAD ANYBODY TURN DOWN FOR
TRANSITIONAL BAD SO WHAT WE WILL
DO IS ORDER AS A SPECIAL
CONDITION OF PAROLE THAT THEY GO
TO TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR SIX
MONTHS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN IN THE
INSTITUTION FOR SO LONG AND THAT
TRANSITION FROM THAT VERY
STRUCTURED ENVIRONMENT.
TO SOCIETY AS A WHOLE CAN BE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM AND
SO MOST OF THEM THAT I GO OUT
AND TALK TO ARE VERY THANKFUL
AFTER A WHILE THAT THEY'VE GONE
TO IT.
INITIALLY THERE NOT SO HAPPY
HOME GOING TO TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING THEY WANT TO GO HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEY WANT TO
YOU KNOW.
GET ON WITH THEIR LIVES MOST OF
THEM REALIZE AFTER ABOUT A MONTH
TWO MONTHS THAT THEY WERE
THEY'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE
HAD THE STEPPING STONE BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT ANTICIPATE.
HOW OVERWHELMING IT WOULD BE?
THAT'S STARTING TO GET BETTER
CONVEYED TO THE INMATES --
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE PEOPLE ON
PRO NOW SO THERE'S MORE PEOPLE
GETTING THAT INFORMATION BACK
INTO THE INTO THE PRISONS.
BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF RE ENTRY
THAT WE DEAL WITH IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THESE KIND OF
STEP INTO THE COMMUNITY PROGRAMS.
OF THAT CDC ARE HAS FOR OTHERS
[inaudible]
YEAH
. 39% THAT ARE APPROVED
AFTER HEARING.
SO OUR RECIDIVISM OFFICIAL
RECIDIVISM RATES -- RANGE FROM.
MEANING A NEW CONVICTION AFTER.
THREE YEARS OF BEING OUT ON
PAROLE AND THE LAST THREE
OUTCOME REPORTS STATES
FLUCTUATED FROM [inaudible]
IT'S ME [inaudible]
I'M. THREE POINT 1% TO FOUR
POINT 2%.
OUR NEW CRIMES AND IN LESS THAN
1% ARE FOR CRIMES AGAINST
PERSONS.
NOW WE'RE TALKING RATHER
[inaudible]
TO OIL.
IT WOULD BE HIGHER FOR PROVIDING
YES [inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
COOL VIOLATIONS.
IF I CAN SUGGEST ONE OF THE
BETTER
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
SO THERE A COUPLE OF THINGS --
IF I MAY -- ONE IS.
I DO YOUR P. THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS HAS
RECENTLY WITHIN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS EXPANDED THE THE LONG
TERM OFFENDER -- PROGRAM TO ALL
INSTITUTIONS.
AND ACCORDING MY COMMISSIONERS
THAT AND DEPUTY COMMISSIONERS
THAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BEST
PROGRAMS -- TO PREPARE PEOPLE
FOR PRO SUITABILITY HEARINGS IS
A COGNITIVELY BASED -- PROGRAM
AND TO THEY LEARN A LOT FROM
FROM GOING THROUGH THAT.
AND SO -- WE'VE SEEN THAT IS
BEING VERY ENCOURAGING FOR
IMPROVING THE SUCCESS OF
RELIGION ARE PROBABLY.
INMATES I'M GOING TO THE RO
PROCESS.
I'M I THINK IT'S IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS I WILL TELL YOU WHEN THE
THINGS THAT WE STRUGGLE WITH IS
A STATE AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE INTEGRITY OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS -- STATEWIDE THAT SEEMS
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT FOCUS THE
MAJORITY THE RESEARCH OUT THERE
WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU SHOULD BE
FOCUSING YOUR RESOURCES ON HIGH
RISK.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HIGH NEEDS
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET THE BEST
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK WE PUT A LOT
OF RESOURCES INTO THOSE FOLKS
AND YOU CAN SIGNIFICANTLY --
DECREASE RECIDIVISM RATES.
I'M IF YOU LOOK AT JUST LONG
TERM OFFENDERS MANY OF THEM HAVE
BEEN DOWN FOR A LONG TIME THEY
DON'T HAVE THOSE SAME KINDS OF
VERY HIGH.
CRIMINAL GENIC NEEDS AND SO THE
ONE THING THAT I CAUTION FOLKS
ABOUT IS IF YOU PRIORITIZE ALL
OFYOUR PROGRAMMING JUST ON WHAT
THE RESEARCH SHOWS WOULD BE THE
BEST.
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK.
I'M.
I THINK IT'S RATHER SHORT
SIGHTED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
LONG TERM OFFENDERS WHO NEED TO
BECOME SUITABLE FOR PAROLE.
BECAUSE THEY TO NEED PROGRAMMING
TO ADDRESSED -- SOME OF THEIR
NEEDS BUT I MOST -- TOOLS ARE
NOT GONNA COME ACROSS IS REALLY
HIGH RISK HIGH NEEDS IN HIGH
RISK.
SO I JUST FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RE
ENTRY IN PREPARING PEOPLE.
ON THE LONG BILL TOP PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD AND THERE'S
A LOT OF OTHER PROGRAMS OUT
THERE.
YEAH YOU YOU YOU REYES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
[inaudible]
EVERY TIME [inaudible]
HE BROUGHT [inaudible]
PROCESS.
AND A LOT [inaudible]
THANK.
WHAT I'VE WHAT I'VE BEEN SEEING
IS PEOPLE WHO ARE DESPERATE?
A LOT MORE.
AND CITIZENS REMAIN.
WHAT I SEE IS?
THIS IS ESPECIALLY [inaudible]
UNDER.
NOT JUST THE SPOT.
I UNDERSTAND WHY.
IN A REIMAGINE THEIR RESPONSE
THEIR OWN MATT.
IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN ACT.
OUT OTHER PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY GET OUT [inaudible]
B. [inaudible]
PORT.
THERE ARE MORE TRANSITIONAL.
THEN THERE HAVE BEEN AT BUT
THERE AREN'T NEARLY ENOUGH.
AND MOST OF THEM DON'T HAVE.
WHAT WE SEE IS PEOPLE AREN'T?
THEY DON'T.
BUT THEY ALSO ARE.
A ALL.
PRIVATE.
DEALING WITH THE PRESS -- FIGURE
OUT HOW TO THE BUS.
SEE THE ROLE IT.
THAT CAN KNOCK SOMEBODY OUT FOR
A WHOLE DAY.
BECAUSE THEY'VE NEVER HAD TO
DEAL WITH THAT AND THERE'S NOT
OF YOUR SUPPORT.
EVEN IF THIS IS TRUE SOMETIMES
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE
IN A TRANSITIONAL PROGRAM.
WHAT DO I DO RAP?
RIGHT BOTH MEN.
IT MAY HAVE A SOLID JOB THEY CAN
DO THAT [inaudible]
BUT A LOT OF TIMES WHAT WE SEE
IS LACKING IS AT OF MISSIONAL.
TO DEAL WITH -- COMING BACK HOME.
AND WHAT IDEA.
BUT ALSO TO DEAL WITH HAVING
BEEN IMPRESSED.
IS THE IS THE PRISON CALLS FROM.
THAT NO ONE DEAL.
NO.
ONE TO DEAL WITH NO ONE IS.
RESOURCE THE DEAL WITH THOSE OF
THE FOLKS TO GET OUT THERE.
THE EIGHTY FIVE BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE THEIR THEIR
POTENTIAL THERE HAS TO BE. TO
REALLY DISRUPT THESE CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE IN THE COMMUNITY THERE
ARE CERTAIN BARRIERS.
THEM DOING THAT -- AND I'M
INTERESTED IN DEVELOPING MORE
WAYS THE TRANSITIONAL PROGRAMS
MORE ROBUST.
DIFFERENT COLOR HOUSING SO THAT
[inaudible]
I
BERMAN [inaudible]
I AM [inaudible] ONE YOU CAN
HEAR ME [inaudible]
DUCK DOWN -- WONDERING -- RE
ENTRY LEASE.
YOU TALK ABOUT [inaudible]
THANKS SORRY
.
WHAT WHAT PEOPLE REPORT IS?
YEAH I GET IN EVEN IF THE
TRANSISTOR.
I HAVE TO USE ALL THOSE TOOLS
THAT ARE AT TO NOT YOU
END TO DEAL WITH ALL THE BAD.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO THAT
[inaudible]
AND THE OVERWHELMING.
BUT I'M JUST LOOKING AT LEARN
[inaudible]
IN THERE [inaudible]
YOUNG.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT RESTORED
[inaudible]
HEARING WHAT [inaudible]
SOMEBODY [inaudible]
COMING [inaudible]
ROLL
.
SYSTEM HOW IT [inaudible]
BETTER
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
NO WORRY -- MORAL
.
I'M AT THE OKAY [inaudible]
EARLY.
ONCE A MONTH WE MEET IN THE ON
BALK WHAT WE CALL A RE BRING
THEM ALL TOGETHER [inaudible]
ACES.
YOU MEET MONTHLY YES
[inaudible]
THAT'S ALL [inaudible]
EARLY THAT [inaudible] FIFTEEN
AND WHERE THEY MEET.
SO OUR OFFICE IS RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- NOT FAR FROM HERE
WE HAVE -- PUBLIC OPEN PUBLIC
BOARD MEETINGS.
AND IT'S PUBLICLY NOTICED AT
TOWARD TEN DAYS IN ADVANCE OF
EVERY HEARING WE USUALLY MEET
DURING THE MONDAY AND TUESDAY OF
THE THIRD WEEK OF EVERY MONTH.
WHERE ARE BASED?
THEY'RE ACTUALLY OUT IN THE
PRISONS SO OUR COMMISSIONERS
TRAVELED EVERY PRISON THEY SPEND
A WEEKEND EACH PRISON WHERE
THEY'RE CONDUCTING HEARINGS --
MOST OF THEM OF EVAN HOTELS --
VERY FEW OF THEM LIVE CLOSE
ENOUGH TO PRISON WHERE THEY CAN
GO HOME AT NIGHT SO WE HAVE
MONDAYS ARE ARE TRAVEL AND
PREPARATION DAYS.
SO FREQUENTLY THEY'LL HAVE A FOR
A FIVE HOUR DRIVE TO GET TO
WHEREVER THEY'RE GOING.
AND THEY PREPARE FOR HEARINGS
THEY THEN CONDUCT HEARINGS ON
TUESDAYS WEDNESDAYS AND
THURSDAYS AND FRIDAYS -- FRIDAYS
WE HAVE ONE OR TWO LESS HEARINGS
AND WE GIVE THEM TIME TO TRAVEL
HOME.
THEN THEY PREP EVERY NIGHT AND
EVERY WEEKEND.
IT IS A FULL TIME JOB.
MORE THAN OF SO WHAT HAPPENS IS --
FOR MONTHS IN ADVANCE OF A
PAROLE HEARING WE ASSIGNED
COUNSEL WE APPOINT EVERY INMATE
THEIR COUNSEL.
SO THERE'S A SERIES OF
INTERACTIONS.
NOW THEY CAN IF THEY HAVE
PRIVATE FUNDS THEY CAN HAVE A
PRIVATE ATTORNEY BUT THE MOST
PART.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY.
OF YES THREE WE END UP HIRING
FOLKS IS SIMILAR.
SO.
BACK MAY DROP OUT AT SOME POINT
DURING THAT FOUR MONTHS THEY MAY
REQUEST A POSTPONEMENT THEY MAY --
REQUEST A WAIVER.
OR THEY MAY SAY WE WANT TO
STIPULATE. TO BEING UNSUITABLE.
AND SO THEY MAY NOT GET ALL THE
WAY TO THE END IN EACH OF THOSE
CASES SO THAT'S HOW THE FEE
STRUCTURE WAS ORIGINALLY.
BUT TOGETHER MANY YEARS AGO.
EIGHT NINE YOUR LOOK.
THAT.
SO ALL THESE [inaudible]
BROUGHT.
IRAQ I'M THERE AT WILL --
THERE'S ABOUT THIRTY NINE OF
THEM STATEWIDE I BELIEVE RIGHT
NOW THEY SERVE ON PANELS WHICH
MEANS -- A THEY HAVE DESIGNATED
INSTITUTIONS ARE WHERE THEY SAY
I WANT TO REPRESENT PEOPLE IN ON
ONE OF THESE PANELS.
IN THOSE LOCATIONS [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
WE ARE [inaudible] EIGHT LAST.
IT'S BEEN ABOUT TEN YEARS.
AT TEN YEARS [inaudible]
WHY IT?
A LOT OF REASONS -- ONE IS THAT
AGAIN WE HAVE NOT HAD A
RECRUITMENT PROBLEM AND WE HAVE
FOUND THAT BOOKS HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE.
RELUCTANT TO INCREASE THAT IS IF
WE HAVE WAITING LISTS OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SERVE ON THESE
PANELS.
AND THEN WHAT WE'VE DECIDED IS
THAT -- IF WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW.
IS THAT WE WANT TO INCREASE THE
EXPECTATIONS SO WE'RE GOING TO
INCREASE THE EXPECTATIONS YOU
WILL MEET WITH YOUR CLIENT X.
NUMBER OF TIMES FOR X. AMOUNT OF
TIME.
YOU WILL -- REVIEW THE RISK
ASSESSMENT WITH THEM IN DETAIL
YOU WILL I'M HELP DEVELOP ROLE
PLANS THINGS LIKE THAT IF WE
WANT TO BUILD IN THOSE
EXPECTATIONS.
IT'S A LITTLE HARD TO ASK THEM
TO DO THAT BASED ON THE SAME DAY --
ALMOST DOUBLE [inaudible]
SEVEN YES.
WE DID THAT SO WE DID THE STUDY
OF WHAT OF WHAT THE OTHER
COUNTIES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE DOING.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WOULD MAKE SENSE AND SO WE
ACTUALLY DID A LITTLE BIT OF
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE BREAKDOWN
IS ALSO FOR APPELLATE.
COUNSEL OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROJECT.
AND THE BREAKDOWN OF DOLLARS FOR
EACH LINES OF THINGS AND HOW
MANY HOURS THEY CAN MAX OUT AT
FOR EACH OF THOSE THINGS AND IT.
IT WAS THE ONE THAT MADE MOST
SENSE IT SEEMED TO KIND OF
ACTUALLY DID IT IN TWO DIFFERENT
WAYS WHERE WE THE CALIFORNIA
APPELLATE PROJECT.
THE SCHEDULE AND SAT DOWN AND
SAID OKAY IF YOU'RE DOING A PRO
HEARING.
WHAT'S ANALOGOUS IN HIM UP WITH
A NUMBER THE MEANTIME OTHER
STAFF ACTUALLY IT THE WHOLE
SURVEY WITH THE OTHER COUNTIES
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHEN WE ARRIVED AT THE SAME
NUMBER HE SAID I MUST BE HAD?
SO WE'RE OPEN FOR YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL IF SOMEBODY HAS OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT WE THOUGHT
THAT THAT WAS THE MOST ANALOGOUS
TO US.
AND IT'S SOME FRAMEWORK THIS IS
A VERY UNIQUE AREA OF THE LAW WE
DON'T WE COULDN'T FIND TOO MANY
OTHER.
PEOPLE OR ENTITIES THAT DO THIS
THE WHERE WE COULD.
IN WHAT THEY DO AND UP BY US SO.
THAT WAS THE BEST WE COULD COME
UP WITH IF SOMEBODY HAS OTHER
IDEAS WERE OPEN [inaudible]
BOB -- HE FOR MAC.
YOU'RE IN A WORD THAT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA WORK [inaudible]
YOU HAVE [inaudible]
BRIAN [inaudible]
WELL MAYBE.
I'M GOING I'M [inaudible]
BILLABLE HOURS [inaudible]
GOING.
WHAT WE WERE PLANNING?
NOW IS THE WAY -- TO I WILL SAY
I MEAN YES I THINK THAT YOUR
CRACK THE ONE A DAHLE AGE THAT
THAT THAT IS LIKELY GOING TO
HAPPEN I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT.
OPERATE IN THIS ARENA OR MANY OF
THE PRIVATE COUNSEL THAT WOULD
PROBABLY TAKE THIS ON IF.
THESE WERE INCREASED A BIT AND
IT WAS MORE FINANCIALLY --
ACCEPTABLE TO THEM [inaudible]
I'M.
THEY REALLY WANT TO DO THIS WORK
IT'S A CALLING FOR THEM THIS IS
NOT.
THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT IS IN IT FOR THE MONEY.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
NECESSARILY A THING [inaudible]
BE HONEST [inaudible]
OTHER.
ABOUT A LOT COOLER WEATHER.
THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS -- WHY?
IT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION --
WE WE HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT
LETTING GO THIS FAR IS THE WHAT.
INCREASED BE SCHEDULE FOR MORE
EXPERIENCED ATTORNEYS I WILL
TELL YOU SOME OF THE FOLKS OF
THE BEST THAT REPRESENTING
INMATES OF THE ONES THAT ARE
STILL IN LAW SCHOOL.
WE'VE BEEN FANTASTIC.
SO YOU DO GET SOME PEOPLE THAT
ARE VERY VERY EAGER AND VERY.
SHARP AND THIS IS NOT I NEVER.
IT'S NOT A REALLY COMPLICATED
FROM A PROCEDURAL STANDPOINT BUT
OF LEGAL ARENA IT'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING.
AND SO IN SOME RESPECTS.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T BE
A FULL TIME JOB FOR PEOPLE MAYBE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
SUPPLEMENTS A PATH -- THEIR
PRACTICE AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THEY REALLY WANT TO DO IT'S VERY
FULFILLING WORK I THINK THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY DO IT.
SO I'M HOPING [inaudible]
AT IBM [inaudible]
LAST [inaudible]
FALL.
RIGHT WHAT WHAT.
WHAT NUMBER?
IT'S NOT TOO FAR FROM -- BEARS
[inaudible]
IN.
IN MY STUDENTS [inaudible]
REPRESENT.
THE TO WORK WITH THEM.
FOR YOU'RE A LONGER.
ADVANCE THAT HEARING.
AND THEY'RE A SUCCESS RESPECT
THEM BETTER THAN MINE.
THERE REALLY COMMITTED TO IT.
MIGHT GET A LOT OUT OF IT.
THEY SPEND A LOT MORE TIME.
YOU MENTIONED YOU KNOW YOU
FURTHER WHAT I THOUGHT BY THE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
I WANT TO WEAR BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT IT.
IT'S JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THE WORK THEY WERE DOING IS
[inaudible]
ESPECIALLY HIRES.
WE'RE ASKING THEM.
TO FORCIBLY [inaudible]
MOMENT BY.
AND WE'RE WE'RE ASKING TO DO
THIS.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS BUILT.
TO OF IS BUILT TO OR OR AT LEAST.
THE WAY TO THE IT REQUIRES THEM.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
AND THAT ALSO MEANS [inaudible]
ACKNOWLEDGING [inaudible]
E..
OWN ABILITIES WE AND THEY'VE
SPENT DECADES [inaudible]
FIVE TEAMS TEAM.
MA'AM THE BLACK TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE THE THING THEIR MOST
BREDA.
THE MOST PAINFUL HISTORIES
MEMBERS.
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE TO THE
VISITING ROOM WITH ME OR MY AND
MY TEAM?
THEY HAVE TO REMOVE THAT ARMOR.
AND LET THEMSELVES BE SEEN. FOR
THE TWO HOURS AWAY TO GET.
AN EXPRESSIVE HIRES.
WHERE THEY'RE NOT GOING OUT INTO
A MORE SUPPORTIVE THERAPEUTIC
COMMUNITY AT THE END OF OUR
MEETING?
YOU CAN ALMOST PHYSICALLY SEE
THEM WITH THEIR ARMOR BACKBONE.
GO OUT.
TO BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T
BE RAW OUT CAN BE VULNERABLE.
AND IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO STEP
BACK.
SOMEONE.
MUST TO IN THAT WAY.
AND AND WE HAVE A MAJOR
OBLIGATION ALL THAT [inaudible]
PROTECT.
SO THE WE'RE NOT OPEN UP.
ROOMS THAT ARE GOING TO GET THEM.
IT TAKES A WHILE TO DIFFERENT
PROCESSES BY SAID IT'S MUCH MORE
PRONOUNCED THANK.
ORDER.
THEN JUST PLUG IT IN IT EARLY.
AND WHAT HEARING.
I LOOK FORWARD.
TO EXPANDING THE ROLE OF WORK.
THAT NECK WITH [inaudible]
HE ASK [inaudible]
I'M PLEASED.
THERE'S NO SUPPORT BY THE
PRESENT ACT.
THE BILL WEST -- UNDER MORE LIKE
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER.
BUT ANY OF THE FOUR FOUR OR FIVE
ITEMS RELATED TO THIS ITEM.
RIGHT SO I AM GOING TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU ARE WE
DIDN'T WANT THEM WAY IN YET GO
AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR JUST NAY NEWMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
TOOK OVER.
AN IMPEDIMENT FIVE BROADER THAN
THAT.
WE BELIEVE THAT BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL.
AND THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE GOING
TO INCREASE NUMBER HEARINGS THAT
ARE HEARD.
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT.
YOU TO FINDING CANCELLATION.
POSTPONEMENTS WILL GET CLOSER TO
THAT 39% OR SO GRANT RATE IT
ACTUALLY COMES ABOUT WHEN.
I'VE GOT.
YOUR CASE I'M WE ARE ACCEPTING
AGAIN LIMITED EDITION.
FIRST TWO YEARS AND CORRECTIONAL
[inaudible]
HELP.
AN INMATE I'M [inaudible] FOR
THEM.
AS TO THE MAY BE SCHEDULED BET
OR PROCURING.
ON THAT IN THE END NINE COUNTIES
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
AVERAGE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY DOLLARS PER CASE.
WHY WE BELIEVE IT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLAR FEE IS REASONABLE?
FORWARD WE ALSO WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF MANY BUILDING.
THERE WE ARE THINKING ABOUT.
PROVIDING ADEQUATE [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH [inaudible]
THIS.
OVERALL PROPOSAL IS NOT ONLY
LOOKING AT YOU WITH AN INCREASE
IN BACKLOG IN THOSE THE HAVE TO
MOLD EQUIPMENT YOU NEED EXPERT
BARRED LIST OF ANY CHANGES WE
MAKE BUT IT'S UNCLEAR.
AND SO YOU KNOW I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BETTER AS I HE
IS [inaudible]
HI. TO A NEW.
COOL THAT'S GOING TO BE USED.
IN THE PROCESS BEGAN A ONE IT SO.
I'M GONNA NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT BETTER.
AND IS IT SAYS HE IS GOING
PROCESS INCREASINGLY COMPLEX.
IN OBVIOUS YES WE HAVE A POOL OF
ALL LOT MORE [inaudible]
HEARINGS.
BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
[inaudible]
WHETHER.
FROM WHEN I READ.
HE YOU KNOW ARE WE IN NEW
SOFTWARE WE TALKING.
AIDED.
BUT MEN.
AROUND THE NEAR BRING ME NOW
WOULD LIKE.
AND THAT BETTER [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY HE BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR [inaudible]
FROM THE FROM WHAT I KNOW THAT.
BOTH THE VOTERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE.
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF AIRINGS
EVERY YEAR THAT.
THAT MIGHT BE THE ARGUMENT
[inaudible]
HOWEVER [inaudible]
WHAT?
NO THIS GONNA JUMP BY ANY MEANS.
I'M LOW'S ADD A LOT MORE
PERMANENT EVE BUT WE'RE HAVING A
LOT MORE HEARING.
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING.
THE ROLE OF TEMPORARY HE IS IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A REDUCTION.
IN HERE.
I CAN UNLESS OF COURSE BE
ACHIEVED A BETTER RATE.
OF THE APPROVAL FOR PAROLE BUT I
CAN EXPLAIN THAT PROBABLY QUITE
QUICKLY I'M FOR AN INITIAL
HEARING.
AN INMATE INITIAL HEARING
COUNSELORS HAVE TO WHAT WE ASK
THEM TO DO THE DUTY THAT THEY
CARRY OUT THE BOARD.
IS TO SUMMARIZE THE OFFENDERS
ENTIRE CENTRAL FILE SO WHEN THEY
BEEN DOWN.
FOR ALL RIGHT WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR TEN OR TWENTY
YEARS.
IT'S AN ENORMOUS BACK FILE OF
INFORMATION THEY SUMMARIZE FOR
US.
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED YOU KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE THE INFLUX OF THE BUBBLE.
DUE TO THE COURT CASE AND THE
YOUTH OFFENDERS IN PARTICULAR
WHERE WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
FAR MORE INITIAL HEARINGS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT TWO YEARS
THEN WE WILL THEREAFTER.
SO THEY'RE JUST ASKING FOR SOME
TEMPORARY -- POSITIONS TO HANDLE
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S GONNA TAKE
MORE TIME FOR THOSE COUNSELORS
TO HANDLE THESE CASES
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
THAT.
IS.
A DECENT EXPLANATION THOUGH I'M
NOT SURE IT EXPLAINS IT OR ARE.
ELEVEN LIMITED NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE LIMITED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT WHATEVER -- AND
THEN THE ADDITIONAL.
WHAT I HOPE WHAT IT IS BUT
SOMETHING MORE ON THIS
[inaudible]
VISION MAKING [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT I'M -- BUT THERE ARE
OTHER QUESTIONS WILL GO TO OUR
NEXT ITEM IS WIDELY -- SORRY
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE PUBLIC PROMINENCE BY
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE I AM AN INMATE IN FAMILY
ADMIT IT.
I ALSO HAVE A HAS BEEN
INCARCERATED IN WHEN IT. ONE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
BILL MY ISSUE IS -- CCAR'S.
NOT NECESSARILY THE PAROLE BOARD
BUT CDC ARE IN GENERAL IS ASKING.
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS -- BUT IN
TODAY'S BUSINESS I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE HEARD OF A GLADIATOR
FIGHTS THAT ARE GOING ON SO
THEY'RE PROMOTING AND BEATING
VIOLENCE AND THESE REASONS.
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY ALL THE
WILL NOT ALL BUT SOME OF THE
GUYS IN THERE ARE LOSING THEIR
PAROLE THEIR PAROLE DATE.
BECAUSE WITH THE NEW PROGRAM THE
NON DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITY THERE ANY GRADING SO
WHY POPULATIONS ANGIE.
ELECTIONS WOULD HAVE WHICH HAVE
BEEN SEPARATED FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS.
STILL THAT'S BEATING VIOLENCE
AMONG THE INMATES IN THE LOWER
LEVEL FACILITIES AND MOST OF
THESE -- INTEGRATIONS ARE
HAPPILY HAPPENING AT THE LOWER
LEVEL FACILITIES WHERE THEY'RE
LIKE EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF COMING
HOME.
IN FOR EXAMPLE AN ORIGINAL
TRAINING FACILITY IN DECEMBER.
THERE WAS AN INMATE THAT WAS
COMING HOME IN TWO WEEKS.
BUT A HUGE RATE OCCURRED IN HIS
FACILITY BECAUSE OF THIS MERGER
AND NOW HE'S SITTING IN THE HOLE
IN THE IN A FACILITY FACING
ATTEMPTED MURDER CHARGES.
SO THE DA WILL POSSIBLY EITHER
PICK IT UP OR NOT IS JUST
WAITING FOR THAT.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
AFFECTING THESE GLADIATOR FIGHTS
THESE EMERGES NOTONLY WITH THE
NON DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITY -- THAT.
THAT CDC ARE CREATED LAST YEAR
BUT ALSO INCREMENTAL RELEASES
THERE ARE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
STATE BUSINESS RIGHT NOW WHERE
DID YOU SEE OUR IS.
KNOWINGLY PLACING KNOWN ENEMIES
OUT IN THE YARD OR STAY LOOTED
AREAS LIKE JIM AREA AND MAKING
ON BY.
ALL THESE INCIDENTS -- MA'AM YOU
STATED THAT YOU KNOW WHEN THE
FOR THEIR THEIR PAROLE HEARINGS.
THE IF THEY GET THE NIGHT OF THE
YEAR DIALING EIGHT MONTHS IN MY
ROLE.
BUT WITHIN THOSE EIGHTEEN MONTHS
IN THEIR PLACE AND ONE OF THESE
DISABILITIES.
THEY'RE ACTING IN SELF DEFENSE
AND AND HAVE TO FIGHT FOR THEIR
LIVES.
AND NOW THEY GET A ONE FOR BEING
AN AGGRESSOR AND THEY'RE LOSING
THOSE STATE THEN THEY'RE LOSING
THEIR CHANCES I'M HOME AND YOU
KNOW ALL THIS VIOLENCE THAT SEAT
IS YOURS CREATING A IT'S JUST.
YOU KNOW ALL THESE BILLS ARE
PASSING TO THEIR LOVED ONES HOME
AND ALL THESE BILLS ARE PASSING
TO THEIR LOVED ONES HOME.
AND ALL THESE LIGHTS IN ALL
THESE GLADIATOR.
I'M SORRY.
OUR LOVED ONES ARE IN.
MENTAL AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY DRAINED.
YOU KNOW AND ALL THESE.
ALL THIS VIOLENCE AT CDC OR IS
CREATING IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
TODAY IS JUST -- THEIR CHANCES
ARE PART OF COMING HOME --
LIMITED.
YOU KNOW AND IT'S THEIR DRAINED
WHERE THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE THE ONES CHOSEN
TODAY. TO GO OUT AND FIGHT THEY
DON'T KNOW OF THEIR LIFE IS
GOING TO BE PLACED IN DANGER.
THEY DON'T KNOW -- IF THERE THEY
GO TO THEIR COMMITTEE AND THE
BEFORE THEY WANTED TO GO TO A
LOWER LEVEL SO THEY CAN GO TO
PAROLE AND SAY YOU LOOK I'M
DOING GOOD I'M PROGRAMMING.
BUT RIGHT NOW NOWADAYS YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO TO THEY DON'T WANT TO
GO TO A LOWER PRISON BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID.
ALL THE LEVEL ONE PRISONS NOW
ARE NON DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITY THE LEADER IN OUR
MOVEMENT HER HUSBAND WAS PLACED.
IN A NON DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITY IN RG DONOVAN LAST
MONTH. THREE TIMES THREE
INCIDENTS HE WAS BEING BRUTALLY
ATTACKED LESSONS BASS LESSEN THE
NECK.
AND HIS HE WAS A LEVEL ONE MINUS
NEGATIVE TWENTY TWO POINTS.
I MEAN.
AND IT IS FOR PAROLE MAKE YOU
NEED IF YOU IS GONNA COME HOME
IN MAY BUT HE WAS PLACED IN HIS
YARD.
AND BRUALLY ATTACKED.
YOU KNOW SO ALL THE SO.
YOU KNOW I I WON OUR LOVED ONES
TO COME HOME AND BUT THE
VIOLENCE THAT'S BEING CREATED
INSIDE THE PRISONS IT'S LIMITING
THEIR OPTIONS -- ACTUALLY LET
YOU GUYS KNOW I AM DOING GOOD
AND PROGRAMMING YOU KNOW BE HIS
BILL SEE ALL THESE.
ONE MEANS AND YOU KNOW AND HAVE
AN ALL STATE PRISON THE THE
GENTLEMAN -- THAT.
THERE IS THERE A FEAR FOR THEIR
LIVES.
THEY SAID I'M NOT GONNA PROGRAM
BECAUSE I I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
GONNA BE ATTACKED.
THEY WERE WRITTEN UP BECAUSE THE
RE USE THE GOAL THE OTHER YARD
TO GO TO THE EAST THE YARD.
AND THEN THE WERE RAIN UP AGAIN
AND LABELED AS THE PROGRAM.
AND NOW TO WRITE UPS IN THREE
MONTHS THEY'RE BEING PLACED ON
THE STATUS.
AND AND LABELED AS PROGRAM.
SO YOU KNOW ALL ALL THESE YOU
KNOW.
THE BOTTOM LINE -- WE JUST.
WOULD LIKE CDC ARE TO FOLLOW
THEIR MISSION STATEMENT OF THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF OUR LOVED
ONES.
AND THEY WERE PROGRAMMING FINE
BEFORE IT THE NON DESIGNATED
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY ON BEFORE THE
INCREMENTAL RELEASES.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE STATE IS
NOW CREATING YOU KNOW SO.
NOW THEY DON'T LOOK GOOD IN THE
EYES OF THE PAROLE BOARD AND
THEIR CHANCES OF COMING HOME
HAVE DIMINISHED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC ON ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENT
[inaudible]
THE MY I'M GONNA ASK YOU
DELIVERY.
GO AHEAD I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARY LOU GARCIA.
AND I WANTED TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT -- AND WE'RE
ALREADY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST -- I KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE CONCERNED.
ABOUT -- HOW TO MAKE PEACE --
PROGRAMS WORK AND HOW TO HOW --
TO YOU KNOW BE ABLE. TO TO
IMPLEMENT.
IS BUGET OR IT'S A PROCESS THAT
ACTUALLY WORK.
I'M.
I MYSELF HAVE A LOVED ONE
INCARCERATED I'M ALSO AT IT AND
YOU KNOW I HAVE IN MY HAND THE
REPORT FROM.
THE ON ON AUDIT I WAS AND THAT
IS NOT THAT LONG AGO -- AND THIS
IS -- FOR SEVERAL --
ADMINISTRATIVE UP OR
ADMINISTRATIVE PRACTICES FROM
CDC ARE AND YOU KNOW IT STATES
HERE THAT AFTER THE REALIGNMENT
CORRECTIONS BEGINNING USING
INMATES.
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT -- YOU KNOW
THESE PROGRAMS WORK.
AND YOU KNOW AND MAYES I'M HOME.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THAT
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW THESE --
ACTRESSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY AND
IN PLAYS THESE POOR PRACTICES.
YOU KNOW INMATES HAVE BEEN
DENIED.
OF PROGRAMMING SO I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU GUYS ARE AWARE BUT IN
PARTICULARLY -- AND I SPEAK OF
CTF BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE MY
LOVE WHEN IS -- THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN PROGRAMMING FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND I'M YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO HUG HIM IN SIX MONTHS.
AND YOU KNOW THEY HAVE BEEN
DENIED -- TO THEY HAVE BEEN THE
NIGHT OF SEVERAL ACCESS.
SUCH AS JUST.
I'M SORRY I'M A LITTLE.
NERVOUS LET ME GET IT TOGETHER
THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED OF SEVERAL --
PROGRAMS SUCH AS EDUCATION TRADE
WORK PI SELF HELP GROUPS
RELIGIOUS SERVICES.
FAMILY CONNECTIONS --
VISITATIONS AND THERE IS NO RULE
OF LAW BUT IN CASE YOU KNOW TO
THIS POINT WE HAVE CONTACTED
SEVERAL CBC OUR MEMBERS.
GIVEN THE RUN AROUND THERE IS
NOTHING YOU KNOW IN PLACE THERE
IS NO COMMUNICATION THERE IS NO
INFORMATION.
IF ANYTHING IS GONNA YOU KNOW
HAPPEN OR CHANGE AND OUR LOVED
ONES ARE DESPERATE BECAUSE AS AS
YOU KNOW MY PARTNER MENTIONED.
THIS IS THE LOWER LEVEL.
AND MOST OF THESE INMATES ARE
GETTING READY FOR BOARD SO MORE
THAN YOU KNOW ATTORNEY
REPRESENTATION MORE THAN.
YOU KNOW.
PSYCHOLOGICAL HELP COUNSELING
HELP OR WHATEVER THESE FOLKS
NEED TO BE READY. TO COME UP TO
COME OUT TO THE REAL WORLD AND
AND YOU KNOW BE ABLE TO FUNCTION
OUT IN SOCIETY -- WITHOUT THESE.
SERVICES AND WITH YOU KNOW.
THEIR RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED.
AND YOU KNOW.
THEIR RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED AND
EVERYTHING BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM THAT'S NOT GOING -- THESE
BOOKS ARE IN THE MENTAL STATE
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE JUST
CALLING OUT WORK AS THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS FOR HELP ME AS THEY FEEL.
HELPLESS DAY THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR THEMSELVES IN.
YOU KNOW I MYSELF.
I MYSELF YOU KNOW I'M JUST
ASKING I DROVE FROM WE ALL BROKE.
FROM LOS ANGELES.
YOU KNOW SO ARE YOU GUYS READY
LUCK IN.
MATTER.
HAS.
NOBODY HAS AND CBC ARE HAS TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT IT
HAPPENING.
AND YOU KNOW -- I JUST AS YOU
GUYS KNOW.
LOOK INTO THIS MATTER AND ARE
ABLE TO ASSIST WITH YOU KNOW
BEING ABLE TO REINSTATE ALL
THESE PROGRAMS THAT.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMMING
PHOTO BOARD AND HAVE SOMETHING.
FOUR I MEAN I MYSELF YOU KNOW WE
ASK FAMILY MEMBERS WE ARE
DRAINED WE DON'T KNOW WHERE ELSE
TO GO.
WE'VE ASKED WORST BOARD AND HE
SPOKE IN THERE I MEAN IF YOU CAN
ONLY IMAGINE IF WE ARE OUT HERE
ARE MENTALLY BRAIN.
WHAT THEY ARE GOING THROUGH IS
IS DOES?
IT'S AN HUMANE.
THANKS AND WE ASK THAT REALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T WANT TO BUT I AM I ACT.
M. DO NOT HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT IN OUR STRAIGHTER HAS MANY
OF THE PATIENTS.
I AM A NERD FOR A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
BUT I FOUND OUT THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING THROUGH LIKE VERY
SMALL I NEVER OBSCURE INTERNET.
SITES AND THINGS.
SO I ACT.
THEN.
AND I ASKED IF THERE IS ANYTHING
THAT I DO LIKE ON THEIR BEHALF
AND AS I EIGHT FIND OUT MORE.
FROM THEM BERMAN THE FAMILIES OF
PEOPLE THAT -- ARCHERY DATING
AND LIKE OF THE WHOLE.
PROCESS WORK AND EVERYTHING IT
IT'S UP.
RIGHT MEANS THAT THESE TYPE OF
PRACTICES THEY'RE TAKING BASED
IN THE PRISONS -- FOR EXAMPLE OF
THE MENTION THE VIOLENCE AND
EVERYTHING THAT THEY ARE.
BEING AS THESE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO REHABILITATE AND REENTER
SOCIETY -- BUT ANOTHER THING
THAT I THINK.
REALLY BEEN -- EXPLORED AT EVEN
AS THE AS A WORKER THERE I WORK
FOR THE COUNTY OF ANGELES.
OFFICERS BETTER IN THAT.
THERE ARE ALSO AT RISK.
BECAUSE OF THIS POOR
IMPLEMENTATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S PROBABLY.
FOR BUDGETARY REASONS.
EVERYONE AT THE LOWER LEVEL
FACILITIES BUT THE WAY THAT IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED.
IS VERY WEIRD IT'S CUMBERSOME IT.
BY THE DANGER -- YOU KNOW.
SO FAR THERE HAVE BEEN TWENTY
THREE INCIDENTS AND COUNTING AND
LEASING ABUSING FOOD -- ASSAULTS
UP SPLASHING IN BATTERY OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO
INCORPORATE ARE NOW BEING
WRITTEN UP -- YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS VOLUNTARY --
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THAT THE MONEY THAT IS
BEING ALLOCATED THESE STORIES.
IS BEING USED.
IN ARE A WHY IS JUDICIARY MANNER
IF THEY DON'T HAVE OVERSIGHT.
WOULD BE SOME KIND OF OVER I
KNOW THAT THIS MONEY IS USED
ACTIVITY. FOR WHAT IT IS GETTING
PEOPLE READY YOU KNOW FOR PAY
THEIR DEBT IT AND NOW BE ARE TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO SOCIETY AND
BEING THEM IN THESE GLADIATOR
FIGHT.
TYPE OF YOU KNOW BY THE WHITE.
SURVIVAL TYPE OF OF YOU KNOW
SITUATION IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
AND ALSO LIKE THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
TRAUMA THAT THEY GO THROUGH.
THEIR COULD LOCK DOWN THEY'RE
NOT CALLING IT LOCKED DOWN SO
THERE'S A LOT OF OF LIKE
MAYBELLINE AND STUFF THAT'S
GOING NINE POLITICKING.
WORDS NOT BEING CALLED A
LOCKDOWN MODIFIED PROGRAM
THEY'RE IN THEIR SPELLS.
YOU KNOW SO THERE'S A LOT OF
REALLY AN UNCLEAR STUFF
HAPPENING WITH THIS SITUATION.
AND I YOU KNOW SOMEONE IN THE
INTO IT.
FINANCIAL COST I MEAN OF HAVING
PEOPLE ARE TREATED IN I MEAN OUT
IN.
IT WITH LIKE YES BE. FOR IT
PORTER SOCIALIZATION.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE BENEFICIAL TO
THEM [inaudible]
ANYWAY.
THANK YOU THANK.
MY NAME IS THE LETTER ME AS I AM
NOT -- SITE AND I WROTE DOWN
WHAT I WANTED.
EIGHT MY HUSBAND HAS ALSO I'M
GONNA SEE FOR NEXT YEAR.
ARE YOU UNDER.
AND ALSO WAS PART OF THE PUBLIC
CAN BE.
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE DISORDER THAT
HAS THE RALLY.
PARK DAY PRESENTING SOME PRISON
SOUTHERNERS HAVE BEEN ON
MODIFIED PROGRAM.
YOU TO FRESNO STATE.
REASONABLE DOG POPULATION THE
WHO DOES NOT WANT A PROGRAM WITH
OTHER GROUPS SINCE AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND I HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
TALK WITH HIM TO ALLEVIATE THE
PROBLEM BUT GOING BACK ON THE
WORD AND ATTACKING OTHERS.
BULLDOGS HAVE SEPARATED.
HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FROM A
DIFFERENT GROUP ARE OVER THIRTY
YEARS BECAUSE OF THIS THING
STERN.
YOU MUST BE IS THEM.
TEXAS WILL BE SEPARATED BULLDOGS
FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
AND PROGRAMMING HAS DONE WITH NO
MAJOR PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ONE SINCE
OCTOBER AND SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DEPENDING ON
THE FACILITY WHICH IS NOW GOING
ON SEVEN MONTHS TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY WITH NO SOLUTION IN SIGHT.
AT THE TIER FOR EXAMPLE SO
THERE'S NOT.
HAVE NOT HAD ANY INCIDENTS
CONDUCT OVER BUT BILL THE BILL
DOES HAVE HAD.
SIX AND FOR SOME REASON.
THE BLAME IS ALWAYS BUT ON THE
SOUTHERNERS AND THE LITTLE
PROGRAMMING THAT THEY HAD HAS
BEEN TAKEN AWAY.
THE DC ARE KNOWS THE DANGERS
THAT COME FROM INTEGRITY KNOWN
ENEMIES BECAUSE ONE OF THEIR OWN
THE TEN I HAVE BEEN ON WHO WAS
AT CORCORAN STATE PRISON AT THE
TIME WROTE AN ARTICLE IN.
ANATOMY OF A FELT GUARD
INTEGRATION.
THE ARTICLE MENTIONS BLOODY HERE
FIGHTS FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT OF
ADMINISTRATOR.
RIGHTS ARE KNOWN AS CDC ARE. TO
SEIZE YOUR AT UBER MENTAL
RELEASES AND KNOWINGLY. TWO
GROUPS OF ENEMIES I'M BIGGER
TOGETHER AND LET THEM GO AT IT
THE NOVEL RESULT IN INJURY AND
THEY CONTINUE TO DO SO.
WORK IN STATE PRISON.
HEADING INTO INCREMENTAL RELEASE
LAST LAST WEEK.
AND RESULTED IN A SEVERE INJURY
TO A FLASH TOOK BASS.
PLEASANT VALLEY WILL BEGIN
INCREMENTAL RELEASES AGAIN NEXT
WEEK.
HOW MUCH WE'RE BLESSED WILL BE
LOST IN ORDER FOR CDC ART PLEASE?
THE MUSIC TOGETHER.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF AN
INSTITUTION WHOSE SUPPOSED TO
KEEP KEEPING YOUR LOVE?
ONE THREE HE ACTUALLY HEARD IN
THEM.
AND HOW CAN WE SEE HERE IN COLOR
REHABILITATION WHEN THESE MEN
HAVE A PROGRAM AND OVER SIX
MONTHS.
THANK YOU.
FOR ARE YOU GUYS DOING ON MY
NAME'S THE SOME COMMUNITY AYE
ORGANIZER SACRAMENTO ALSO
FORMALLY INCARCERATED JUST
COMPLETED EIGHTEEN YEARS.
OLD BUT A YEAR AGO.
AFTER SPENDING MOST OF MY YOUNG
YEARS IN THERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS I SERVED ON THE MAC
AND I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK AND
IN ORGANIZING THEIR IT AND I
KNOW THE PROCESS. SIX THE TWO
PROCESSES THE GAMES ARE PLAYED I
MEAN.
NOT A PERFECT SYSTEM IT'S IT'S
IT'S A CULTURE OF OF A PRISON
GUARD UNION HAVING A LOT OF
POWER AND CONTROL IN.
A LOT OF THE MICHIGAN JUST.
RIGHT WITH THIS ISSUE RIGHT HERE
I'M NOT A BASH THE DEPARTMENT AT
THAT.
YEAH RIGHT NOW BECAUSE NOW THE
TIME OF WITH THIS IS TALK ABOUT
THAT THIS IS A REALLY AFFECT US
I SEE THAT YOU GUYS NEED MORE
ASSISTANCE FROM WHAT I GATHER.
TO GIVE MORE.
WORLD PANELS TO WE GET SOME OF
THESE NUMBERS AND GET SOME OF
THESE HEARINGS.
I BELIEVE THAT'S A GOOD MOVE TO
KEEP IT GOING BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO START PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE.
CAUSING THIS IMPACT IN THIS
IMPACT BY HERE.
OF MY MOTHER'S MY SISTERS MY
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE I'VE SEEN IT FROM
THE CHAOTIC PERSPECTIVE WERE ON
LOCKDOWN WE ALWAYS.
TAKE ISSUED OUT AND SO THE THE
SOUTHERN THE SOUTHERN HISPANICS
ARE KNOWN AS RENTALS RIGHT IT'S
FOR ALL OF LOS ANGELES.
RIVERSIDE ALL DOWN SOUTH AREAS
THE BIGGEST BIGGEST.
OUT OF OF OF HISPANICS WERE
LABELED.
PRISON GANG MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS A BIG IT'S A
BIG POOL OF OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MADE CHANGES WHO'VE MADE PEACE
TREATIES.
AND IT SHOULD WORK TOGETHER WITH
BLACK AND BROWN AND AND
DIFFERENT -- GETTING OF
POLITICAL PROGRAM WHEN
EVERYTHING WAS GOING SMOOTHLY.
YES PRESS SOME WIRES YET YOUR
BULLDOGS YOU HAD G. P.
EVERYTHING WAS GOING TO MOVE THE
MINUTE WE START THIS MIXTURE.
MADE IN A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
PROBLEMS FOR THE DEPARTMENT -- I
I'LL ASK YOU THAT YOU REALLY
CONSIDER WITH THESE WOMEN SAID
TODAY.
EN EN OF TOMORROW TOMORROW BE
MEETING WITH RALPH THE US AND
SOME SOME OTHER OTHER PROJECTS
YOU KNOW.
HE WAS AT ANOTHER HEARING WHERE
THEY SMASHED ON THE STAT.
I TO KEEP DATA ON ALL THIS WILL
BE MEETING WITH THEM TO TALK
THAT.
TALK ABOUT GETTING MORE RE ENTRY
SUPPORT BECAUSE OF ALL THESE
GUYS ARE PUSHING ALL THESE BILLS.
I'M A SKINNER AND AGAIN OUR
PEOPLE I WILL SEND YOU ARE
PROVIDED WITH WITH HOUSING WITH
THE ENTRY WORK AND I BELIEVE
THAT TO THE BUDGETS OF PAROLE
PROBATION AND CDC ARE WE CAN BE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
DO THE WORK TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
THAT WE KNOW HOW. TO SERVE IT
TAKES PEOPLE FROM THAT COMMITTED
TO SERVE WORKING COLLECTIVELY WE
CAN MAKE SOME IMPACT AND CHANGES
BUT WE HAVE SOME HOUSE CLEANING
TO DO.
AND I'LL HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS CAN
COULD MEET WITH SOMEBODY
ADMINISTRATORS AND AFTER.
THAT DISCUSS NAY CHEN ITEMS WITH
SHOULD YES TOMORROW -- PRESENT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES TO HIM TO
SEE WHAT ARE HIS THOUGHTS THIS
WHOLE WORK COLLECTIVELY. TO TO
TO REALLY RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE GONNA BE
US AGAINST THEM.
WELL WE HAVE THIS US AGAINST
THEM MENTALITY WITH.
SEC P. D. IN THE COMMUNITY SO SO
MOST THINGS ARE BEING HASHED OUT
AND WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT WHERE
WHERE WE ALL CAN WORK TOGETHER
T REALLY RESOLVE THESE THESE
THESE ONGOING ISSUES HAVE BEEN
GOING ON FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING AND
SHARING YOUR EXPERIENCES THAN
INFORMING.
RIGHT.
SO WE WILL MOVE ON OUR NEXT ITEM
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT SO ARE OTHER.
NEVER KNOW THE WHILE THEY MAY
NOT GO TO THE LEAD ACID
REPLACEMENT -- IT'S A SEC
WAITING FROM THOSE -- REQUEST WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT -- TO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS
CARS ACTUALLY.
THE NEXT ITEM IS A REQUEST FOR
TWENTY FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND OR POSITION.
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND I'M
GOING TO ESTABLISH A SEVEN YEAR
SCHEDULED.
FOR REPLACEMENT OF OUR CRITICAL
WEEK.
THIS PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEEN USING
EIGHT MILLION.
FROM OUR BASE SUB.
VISION OF AN OLD INSTITUTION
BUDGET.
FOR WE REPLACEMENT WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO DO THAT FOR A TOTAL
OF THIRTY TWO MILLION.
WITH ME TODAY IS DEVON FONG WHO
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF BUSINESS.
AND NOW -- IN ADVANCE.
GONNA BE WHY DO YOU NEED.
GET IT BY WE NEED.
YEAH.
WHAT'S YOUR OUT TELL ME THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE LIKE DOUBLING THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES I DON'T KNOW
WHY WE NEED.
MORE PEOPLE [inaudible]
AFTERNOON -- SENATORS.
CITIES ARE GRADUATES
APPROXIMATELY 1-002-800-0800 AND
THIRTY FIVE CENTS YOU SHINS AND
FORTY SEVEN CONSERVATION CAMP.
DID YOU SEE OUR AS A LEADER OF
APPROXIMATELY. SIX THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR ON ASK.
THESE ASSETS OR TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT.
FIRE WASTE DISPOSAL -- SERVICE
PLAN OPTIONS.
CDC ARE DOES NOT HAVE A
DEDICATED FUNDING.
MECHANISM FOR US THAT
REPLACEMENT.
LEAD ACID REPLACEMENT.
A CDC ARE AS WANTON MENTIONED
UTILIZED THE A. I. PROGRAM
BUDGET. TO REPLACE ASSETS
PREVIOUSLY.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HELP US
BETTER MANAGE OUR LEAD.
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A BASELINE DATA SO
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY SOME
POTENTIAL.
SAVINGS IN THE IN THE UPCOMING
YEAR.
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
OF CDC OURS ASSETS MEET.
YES RUSH HOLT FOR REPLACEMENT
WHICH IS ABOUT SEVENTY SUMMER.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO I WITH
THIS PROPOSAL IS REPLACE OVER
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD OUR BACKLOG?
OF ASSETS OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY
ASSETS.
I WHICH IS ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
I'M SORRY THREE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX ASSETS
THEY'RE CONSIDERED HIGH PRIORITY.
WITH SMOOTH THEM OUT OVER SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD.
I WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
INDUSTRY STANDARDS.
AND THAT WOULD ALSO -- ENABLES
US TO AVOID SOME HUGE SPIKES AND
AND BUDGET.
PARABLE OF REPLACING YOUR OWN.
TWO CARS AND ONE YEAR.
BUT AMOUNTS DO NOT REPLACING ALL
OF THE ASSETS.
MONTHLY TWO THOUSAND OF OUR
ASSETS ARE ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY YEARS OLD TO ABOUT 20% OF
OUR ASSETS TWENTY YEARS OLD.
AND THE AVERAGE AGE OF OUR IN
YOUR THERE.
REALLY OLD AND OUT [inaudible]
SO -- REPLACING THESE.
IF NOT REPLACE THESE DOESN'T
WHICH IS A RISK.
OUR ABILITY TO PERFORM A MISSION
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS.
OF POTENTIALLY JEOPARDIZING THE
EMPLOYEES MADE.
THE ARM IN IN RESPONSE TO THE
THE NEED FOR THE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS.
WE WOULD BE GOING FROM OUR
CURRENT SPEND IS ABOUT. FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- AND SO TO THE
OR POSITIONS WOULD BE GOING
TOWARDS -- COMPLETING THE
PROCUREMENT SO THAT ARE OFF NON
OFF ON TRACK TO WILL BE GOING
FROM ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WE'RE ADDING. TWO MORE
STAFF AND OUR OPPOSITION -- UNIT
GOING FROM FIVE TO SEVEN TO
RIGHT NOW.
FIVE COMPLETE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE WOULD
GOING TO THIRTY TWO MILLION --
WITH.
SEVEN HELLO ON THE FLEET
MANAGEMENT SIDE.
ARE THE NEED FOR THAT IS TO
REALLY AND LOOK AT OUR
UTILIZATION DATA.
THEY WOULD ALSO BE LOOKING AT
THE DATA MANAGEMENT WITH IN THE
INSTITUTIONS TALK ABOUT
REDIRECTION SOMETHING THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR WITH THE HELP --
ASSET -- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT?
HE AND ALSO TALKING ABOUT AN
OUNCE MEANT TO OUR SYSTEM OF
RECORD AND A SAFETY.
I'M PUTTING AN ADDITIONAL BILLS
TO IDENTIFY.
THE WORK AS FAR AS REMOVAL OF
THE ASSET FROM OUR SYSTEM THE
REGISTRATION OF THE SYSTEM.
SURVEYING OUT THE OLD ASSETS AND
WE AND THAT IN PART.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'LL BE
USING THE FOR HELLO.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE THINK THAT A MORE FREQUENT
REPLACEMENT OF VEHICLES AT THE
ART OF BEST AN OVERALL STRATEGY
MINIMIZE THE COST OF OWNERSHIP.
DOES SEEM REASONABLE AND BY THAT
I MEAN A STRATEGY WHERE VEHICLES
ARE SOLD AT THE POINT WHEN THE
WHEN THEY'RE INCREASE THEIR
ANNUAL CARE AND FUEL COSTS ARE.
TO EAT AT THEIR ANNUAL.
ASIAN.
AND THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH BEST
PRACTICES IN FLEET MANAGEMENT AS
WELL AS THE DIRECTION THAT DEGAS
HAD DIRECTED.
DEPARTMENT.
EIGHT I'M AND I UNDERSTAND TO BE
THE OVER ARCHING PROMISED BEHIND
THIS.
PROPOSAL -- BUT WE DO HAVE TWO
CONCERNS WITH.
THE SPECIFIC TO THE PROPOSAL THE
FIRST IS THAT AS I MENTIONED
IT'S ABSURD PREMISE ON THE
NOTION OF A NUMBER.
OF BATON.
ACHIEVING SAVINGS IN VEHICLE
YOU'LL MAINTENANCE REPAIR AND
RESELL -- BUT THE PROPOSAL DOES
NOT FOR THOSE SAVINGS IT IN
OTHER WORDS IT ONLY ACCOUNT FOR
THE INCREASED COST OF PURCHASING
VEHICLES MORE REGULARLY BUT
DOESN'T ACCOUNT.
FOR WHAT WE THINK WOULD BE
LIKELY REDUCTION IN REPAIR
MAINTENANCE BETTER FROM HAVING A
YOUNGER WE ALL ALL ALL TOGETHER.
I CAN'T I'M GIVEN THE WAY THAT
IS.
THAT THESE PLANS ARE SCHEDULED
OUT IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET BELT
IT APARTMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO RE
DIRECT MONEY TO OTHER PURPOSES --
IF IT DID THIS IT WOULD -- AND
INCREASED FUEL MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR [inaudible]
WE WAIT.
OLDER ON AVERAGE.
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT
REQUIRING CDC ARE TO ASK ME
EVENINGS AND VEHICLE MAINTENANCE
OR REPAIR.
OF FUEL AND RETAIL VALUES.
WOULD LIKELY BE ACHIEVED UNDER
THE PROPOSAL.
THEN WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REDUCE THE
DEPARTMENT BUDGET BY THAT AMOUNT.
AND IMPROVE THE THIRTY TWO
MILLION IN A SEPARATE
APPROPRIATION OF THAT THE ARMY
CAN'T RE DIRECT.
ARE SAID.
AND IF THE VCR IS UNABLE TO
ESTIMATE AIMING WERE HAPPY.
IT'S BEEN DOING.
AM I WANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE MARINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
IN REGARDS ELYAS COMMENTS ON THE
SAVINGS.
WE WANT TO KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
HAS DEFERRED MUCH THE MAIN AND
SONS EXISTING FLEET ARE VERY
LONG TIME TO THE LIMITED
RESOURCES AVAILABLE.
WE EXPECT ANY READ EFFICIENCIES
IN THAT AREA WOULD BE REDIRECTED
INTO A BETTER AND MORE FREQUENT
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR.
OF THE ENTIRE FLEET.
AND IF I COULD JUST ONE MORE
NOTE RIGHT ON ALEJO'S.
RECOMMENDATION OF KIND OF
TRACKING THE SPENDING WE DID
THAT PART OF THE PROPOSAL PUT IT
IN ITS OWN.
LINE WE PROVIDE STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND OTHER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALL WE ARE ENDING AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO REPORT ON ALL RIGHT I'M.
AND I HAVE YOUR WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A MINUTE
OUR MODEL.
MAINTENANCE REPAIR YOU'LL SO WE
CAN IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP A
REALLY GOOD BASS LINE SO WE CAN
IDENTIFY SOME.
POTENTIAL SAVINGS.
WE JUST THAT.
A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND.
LEAD MANAGEMENT AND ACQUISITIONS
USED TO BE A DECENTRALIZED
PROCESS WASN'T UP IN. FOUR YEARS
AGO I WAS BROUGHT UP AT QUARTER
TO THE MANAGER.
REPORTERS PERSPECTIVE SO WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF LOOKING AT THE
DATA.
THE DATA IS LEE -- AN EXAMPLE IS
MORE COME OUT YOU'LL USE IT.
THE BILL BEING USED FOR A BOILER
OR IF ALL WHEN THE PROCESS BY
IDENTIFYING AND AND BEING ABLE
TO TRACK.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE NOT ACTING ON
THIS BUT I AM I'M STILL.
NOT CONVINCED ABOUT THE NEED OR
FTP I DO APPRECIATE THE THE
CHANGING OF HOW WE BUDGET.
FOR THE I'M.
OR PLACEMENT AND ALSO.
DELETE AT HAVING THAT ON A MORE.
MATIC PLACEMENT SCHEDULE BUT EAT
SO [inaudible]
A IT INTO THAT.
MORE LATER IN.
RIGHT SO. FOR NOW.
OF PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS SIDE
OF RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ISSUE AN ON THE COUNSELING FOR
MIDDLE JUSTICE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
UNIT.
AND I KNOW THAT IN ADDITION --
TO TO BE DIRECTOR ONCE IN THE
WORLD WILL BE RETURNING.
YEAH OUR FINAL REQUEST IS FOR
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND FOUR POSITIONS --
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND I'M
GOING.
AND THREE NINE THOUSAND FOR A
ONE TIME CONTRACT FUNDING TO
EXPAND THE RESEARCH CAPACITY.
ON THE UP FOR THE COUNCIL ON
MIDDLE JUSTICE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND AS YOU SAID.
WITH ME IS STEPHANIE WELCH THE
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M.
THEY WILL JUST ASSUME BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IS EIGHT TWELVE MEMBER.
ALL.
BY THE SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
AND ALSO REPRESENTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND THE DEPARTMENT.
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
REMAINED IN OF A REMAINING
APPOINTEES ARE -- AN
INTERSECTION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WORK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND TO PROMOTE DIVERSION SPEND.
TEN THAT THAT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PART DEBT IS PROBATION SHEETS
PAPER HEALTH DIRECTORS.
AND AND INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
THE COUNCIL ITSELF IS CHARGED
WITH IDENTIFYING INVESTIGATING
AND PROMOTING.
BEST PRACTICES IN THE FIELDS OF
MENTION VERSION AND RE ENTRY FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF TRYING TO
KEEP PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
OUR WE ARE PRIMARILY A POLICY
BASED COUNCIL WE DEVELOP A
LEGISLATIVE REPORT EVERY YEAR
THE AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
FOCUS ON ISSUES THAT DOES OUT OF
HOUSING STRATEGIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE RETURNING
HOME.
FROM PRISON AND JAILS AND
CORRECTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES [inaudible]
I'M.
THE EXCITING THING ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO ADD.
IT'D BE THIRTY THAT YOU ARE
COUNCIL IS HAVING THE ABILITY TO
NOT ONLY DO OUR OWN RESEARCH --
BUT TO BASE OUR WORK -- IN A
RESEARCH RIBBON AND DATA DRIVEN.
WHAT THE PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW US
TO DO IS TO DEVELOP -- A
COMPETITIVE ARE IF HE OR A ONE
I'M ON TRACK.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE MONITORING BRAIN WORK.
AND THAT FRAMEWORK BASICALLY
WOULD IDENTIFY BOTH PUBLICLY
FACING AS WELL AS NON PUBLICLY
PASTING DATABASES.
THAT CAN GIVE US AND PROVIDE AS
INDICATORS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
ARE MAKING APPROPRIATE
INVESTMENT THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH BEST PRACTICES PREVENTION.
SO IN SHORT IT WILL GIVE US A
LITMUS TEST OF THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IS SEE IF WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK.
I'M STILL TRYING TO DIVERT
PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
MENTAL HEALTH IT IS.
INCARCERATION.
THE STAFF THAT ARE REQUESTED.
NOT ONLY WILL DEVELOP THE R. E.
AND AND MANAGE THAT PROCESS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO MANAGE THE
FRAMEWORK POPULATE THE FRAMEWORK.
IN HOPES OF CREATING A ON A
STATE LEVEL LIKE DASHBOARD -- IT
WOULD HELP US IDENTIFY FOR
EXAMPLE -- IF WE SEE A SPIKE.
IN LOOKING AT VITAL STATISTICS
THAT PEOPLE ARE AND TIME BY --
OVERDOSE OR THEY'RE ENTERING
INTO JAHRES.
M. THIRTY DAYS AFTER RELEASE WE
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT THAT IT
PROVIDES AS INDICATION OF WHERE
WE AS A COUNCIL. TO DIVE DEEPER
INTO CRITICAL.
RIGHT NOW -- WE HAVE AN ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M THAT.
ASK AT LOOK AT CERTAIN USED.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO ALSO USE
DATA. TO HELP US DETERMINE WHAT
ISSUES WE WANT TO LOOK AT I'M
FINALLY I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS THE AN ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT FROM THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT.
I HAVE BEEN A RESEARCH SIGN.
THE SUPPORTING RESEARCH
SCIENTIST.
ONE WE CAN ACTUALLY -- STAFFING
CONTINUE WORK GUARDED.
WHICH IS WITH COUNTY RESEARCHERS
AND UP AND THESE ARE RESEARCHERS
WERE BOTH.
EXCITED WELL AS THE HEALTH SIDE.
REALLY IDENTIFY BARRIERS.
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT HAS TO
BENEFITS ONE OF COURSE IS JUST
[inaudible]
AIR.
THESE PEOPLE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
TRANSITION FOR A LOT OF SYSTEMS
AND AND THE RECORDS THAT THEY
HAVE.
EARLY FOLLOW THEM WHEREVER THEY
GO -- BUT ALSO -- IMPORTANTLY
FOR RESEARCH IN A VALUATION.
HAVE A BETTER SENSE I'M.
OF WHICH PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING.
PEOPLE PERMITS THAT IS THAT.
WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET SOME
RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
AND HE LAUNCHED A MEDICAL
UTILITY RIGHT THAT.
AND RIGHTLY THAT PROJECT ALLOWS
US TO MATCH -- INFORMATION FROM
THE ART MEDICAL DATABASE. TO
WHETHER OR NOT INDIVIDUALS
EXITING.
WE ARE ARE UTILIZING THEIR
MEDICAL BENEFIT AT WHAT EXTENT
ARE THEY DOING IT OUTPATIENT
SETTING ARE THEY DOING TO MANAGE
ON A MISSION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT WHOLE
PROJECT.
A LOT ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
DEDICATE.
MY MAIN REASON IS THE BETTER-UNDERSTANDING THE BARRIERS TO
DATA SHARING.
AND SO IT'LL BE REALLY HELPFUL
TO HAVE A PERSON AND TO LEAVE
THAT WORK GROUP AND HAVE.
INFORMATION NETWORK -- RIVE OUR
POLICY RIGHT [inaudible]
I'M BERMAN.
AND YOU JUST NAY NEWMAN PARTNER
FINANCE I'M ONE OF THE AND IF WE
FIND IN THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT IT
UTILIZING GENERAL FUND RESOURCES.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE COUNCIL
THE MORE APPROPRIATELY FOCUS ON
PAROLEES ARE JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS AS OPPOSED A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACT FUNDS WHICH
IS HOW THEY HAVE PREVIOUSLY BEEN
UNDER.
I'M IN ON THE RIGHT I'M
[inaudible]
SO THE TO THE REQUEST ONE IS FOR
YOUR ONE I'M ONLY WITH.
RIGHT THE OTHER. ONE TIME ONLY
CONTRACT THAT WOULD -- ALLOW YOU
TO DO -- I THANK.
YOU I AM.
I'M ANYONE FOR YOU.
BOTH I'M ISSUE.
AND ON GO [inaudible]
I'M.
AND I GUESS [inaudible]
IT'S HARD.
WHILE THE LEGISLATORS STAFF
WHICH UNIT I DON'T HAVE ANY
[inaudible]
THE UNIT [inaudible]
IT'S EIGHT DOWN.
WELL THIS BY BROTHER ARBITRATE
ASK WORK.
AND IF I LOOK AT ALL RIGHT.
IF WE LOOK AT ALL UNTIL RESEARCH
NEED.
THAT THE NECESSARY DURING THAT
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND OAKS.
THAT WE HOLD IN OUR STATE.
AT THE MOMENT AND VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE ON
ROLE.
I AND WE HAVE THIS HIGH
RECIDIVISM RATE.
YOU KNOW IF I WERE AN ACADEMIC
AND I WOULD BE STARTING YOU.
IDENTIFY A SERIES OF RESEARCH
THAT MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE HELP
US UNDERSTAND OR MANAGE ANY OF
THIS.
YOU KNOW JUST BY TWENTY FORTY
MAYBE A HUNDRED FULL TIME PEOPLE.
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET AT IS I DON'T SEE WHY ADDING
WHERE PEOPLE THIS UNIT IS REALLY
GOING TO BRING US MUCH VALUE AT
WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE IS LOTS
OF ON GOING RESEARCH.
EXTERNAL [inaudible]
I'M.
AND WE HAD A PARTICULAR.
AREA OF RESEARCH THAT WE FELT
WAS NECESSARY.
THEN IT MIGHT BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO THE MISSION IT.
BACK.
VERSUS ADDING FOR PEOPLE WHEN
I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT RESEARCH
HAVE IN MIND FOR THEM DO.
SO -- YEAH I'M NOT I'M A THE
ADDITION OF OR F. E. I DON'T.
MATERIAL I'VE READ SO FAR
DOESN'T GIVE ME WE'RE JUST.
EIGHT WELL I CAN CERTAINLY GO
BACK AND TRY TO WANT TO BUY MORE
OF WHAT SPECIFICALLY AYE
[inaudible]
DOING AN I TOTALLY RESPECT.
I BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN THE
WORK YOU RESPECT THAT I IF YOU.
I'M AND ASKING.
THE IT.
YOU.
BUT FOR US AS A COUNCIL WE
CURRENTLY ONLY.
AND SO BURKE UP. FOR US IT WOULD
ALLOW AT REALLY.
BE ABLE TO FOCUS SOME OF OUR
WORK [inaudible]
UP [inaudible]
MORE.
IS PLAY AND ALL ALSO BELIEVE
PARTNER WITH SOME OF THOSE.
ORGANIZATIONS WE TRY TO KEEP
TRACK OF ALL OF THE EARTH WE ARE
BACK TO BREAK.
IT.
REMOTE EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
IF YOU THAT A WE EXPANDED I
THINK TWO YEARS AGO AFFECTED
ANYWAY.
ONE IN.
SUBSTANCE THIS ORDER.
THIS WOULD GREATLY ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE STAFF LOOK AT
ONE SUBSTANCE USE AND EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES.
SO WELL AN I PERSONALLY BELIEVE
IT WOULD BUT A BIG DENT IN OUR
ANNUAL REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS
BEING ABLE TO DO A MUCH.
I AM FOR US IT'S NOT AND I'M
[inaudible]
COUNTY -- IDENTIFYING BEST
PRACTICES BEING ABLE.
TO BRING THAT INFORMATION LIKE
THIS THEY I AM ONLY -- WAY AND
SO OF WELL I THINK THERE'S AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK TO DO IN
THE LONG TERM THIS WOULD GO UP.
WITH A VERY PART OF US.
PROVIDE BETTER UP MORE TIMELY
[inaudible]
RECOMMENDED [inaudible]
FOUNDED [inaudible]
MOST.
CERTAINLY FIRE THE HEAD OF THE
UNIT WITH WORST DAFT.
NOT IN THE NOT AT ALL.
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT IT
REALLY GIVES.
LITTLE ABILITY YOU [inaudible]
REAL RESEARCH.
ARE.
YOU HOW ADDING.
FOR IF THAT MIGHT WARRANT
[inaudible]
SO.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT.
I MEAN THE THE ITEMS.
THE DESCRIPTION POOREST GIVE
SOBRIETY OF THINGS THAT THE
RESEARCH MIGHT.
BE DONE BUT AGAIN.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE I
SPOKE WITH THE? FOR MORE THAN.
MY NEEDS ARE MORE THAN PEOPLE --
YOU KNOW OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF
YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE OUT.
PERMANENT BUT OTHER WORDS ANY
ONE ASPECT.
WOULD BE MUCH LONGER TERM -- IT
I WONDER WHETHER IT WE'RE NOT
BETTER.
UTILIZING.
CONTRACTS WITH.
RESPECT TO THIS WORK.
AND USING OUR STAFF TO EVALUATE
IT.
AND YOU AND THEN MAKE REPORT
[inaudible]
WHICH MIGHT.
AN EXAMPLE THAT MIGHT HELP THEM
BUT THERE OF BY ALIVE.
THE R. A. B..
PLAYING A ROLE.
I'M PART OF WHAT I SEE THE VALUE
IN THEY HAVE NOT BEEN -- IS.
FOR SOMEBODY TO HELP.
WORK WITH THEY ARE MEANT WE HAVE
AN IT WE HAVE A LOT.
IT WAS ENDING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE I'M IN.
EIGHT THESE.
AND THIS PERSON CAN ACTUALLY
MEET WITH SOME OF THE TALK ABOUT
HOW TO MAKE THAT DATA AND BILLY
AVAILABLE.
TO ALL THE PEOPLE DOING DISTRICT
EIGHT FOR THE UNIVERSITY I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF CITING.
STASHING GOING ON ABOUT EIGHT A
PORTAL.
AT AT UNIVERSAL DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT.
HE SAID THAT.
THAT WE ARE I'M LEARNING FROM
EACH OTHER AND UNDERSTANDING HOW.
AN INTERVENTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ULTIMATELY AND LEAD.
THIS IS STAFF PERSON IS SOMEONE
THAT PERSONALLY.
WE NEED IS THE LEAD ABLE.
TO INTERACT WITH THOSE THAT ARE.
IN ADDITION I'M SPECIFIC THE
DATA WORK GROUP THAT WE STARTED
WITH COUNTY [inaudible]
I MERRILEES.
AND HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THIS PERSON CAN DO SOME
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH.
ALSO RECOMMEND.
I'LL TAKE YOU THERE.
IT'S PHILLIP EIGHT THEM DOING.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BETTER AND
AND WHICH OF THEIR PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY.
AND SO TO ME THAT'S BY THE
THAT'S WHY THAT PERSON IS NEEDED --
AT AND HE ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
THAT.
RATHER THAN GOING OUT AND
COMMITTING RESEARCH I THINK OUR
JOB.
BILL SELECT DATE MORE RESEARCH
BETTER [inaudible] SEVEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT. THOUSAND SEIU
LOCAL.
ONE THOUSAND YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT
THESE RESEARCH NEEDS THERE'S
BEEN ALL THESE BILLS THIS YEAR.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN ASKING FOR RESEARCH
WITHIN.
THE DEPARTMENT WE THINK THESE
ONE TIME STUDIES CONTRACT.
ARE SNAPSHOTS AND IN TIME YOU
DON'T GET TO THE ON GOING THE
ONLY THING IS WE THINK.
THAT THE FOCUS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN SOME WAY NOT
LOOKING AT THE RIGHT THING.
YOU KNOW BE A CC IS COMING UP
NEXT.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH ALL THE REALIGNMENT MONEY
THAT'S GOING TO THE COUNTY AS WE
LOOKED AT THE REPORTS THE BSS.
YES HE HE HAS.
THEY ASKED FOR SO LITTLE DATA TO
THEIR MONEY ISN'T DONE HOW MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THEY GET
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AMPLE.
REACHED AT MILE THAT SENT DOWN
UNDER THE YOUTH CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL THAT MONEY
IS IT A FACT THAT.
ARE THEY SERVING THESE KIDS ARE
THESE PROGRAMS WORKING DO THEY
LEAD TO RECIDIVISM.
WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS
RESEARCH UNIT LUCK.
AT THOSE KINDS OF OF SITUATION
BECAUSE WE KEEP WE JUST KEEP ON
NOT REALLY FOCUSING ON WHETHER
OR NOT THOSE ARE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND SO WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THANK.
ARE YOU ONLY MENTIONED THE ONE
TIME ONLY YOU ONLY MENTIONED THE
CONTRACT ARE YOU SAYING YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF BOTH CONTRACT AND
OR IF HE BUT WHAT WE LIKE TO SEE
IS THE ON GOING BECAUSE WE THINK
OTHERWISE YOU JUST GET A
SNAPSHOT IN.
TIME IF THEY NEED A SYSTEM TO
SET UP WILL COME UP WITH THE
RUBRIC.
WE THINK THAT THAT CERTAINLY
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
WHERE THEY COULD THEN POPULATE
THOSE AREAS.
BUT WE WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE AREAS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT PARTICULARLY
THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS WHERE
THERE'S BEEN NO OVERSIGHT BY THE
LEGISLATURE SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN REALIGNMENT
WENT THROUGH ITS SO CURSORY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THOSE BSE THE REPORT.
WE NEED THIS UNIT TO COME UP
WITH THE RUBRIC IT REALLY PUTS A
FOCUS ON WHAT IT IS THAT WE NEED
TO BE ASKING THOSE GLOBAL
PROGRAM.
SEE HOW WELL THAT MONEY IS BEING
SPENT.
AT ONE TIME CONTRACT WOULD HELP
TO DO THAT YES WE WOULD BE THE
ORDER.
BUT WE THINK WE NEED ONGOING
STAFF THAT WILL MONITOR THAT.
NOT HAPPENING NOW THEY HAVE A
PROGRAM WITH THE COUNTIES BUT
WHAT HAPPENS PASSED PACKED.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS WE DON'T KNOW
IT'S NOT REALLY BEING REPORTED
THE LEGEND.
THANK.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND I'M CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBER
DANNY OFFER FROM LATIN ADVISORS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
ON MENTAL ILLNESS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
IN ANY OTHER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES
[inaudible]
OR WE OPERATE UNDER THE
DIRECTION THAT THE AGENT.
I THINK WE REALLY LOOK.
I AM WORK IS REALLY SHINE A
SPOTLIGHT IDENTIFY.
I DON'T HAVE BY AYE STORY -- G.
THAT IS WHAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU INDICATED YOU REPORT LET
STATE OR YOUR OR YOU'RE NOT
UNDERSTANDING YOUR BILL I
UNDERSTOOD YOU WERE EVER I I I
AM ARE THE BUT THE REPORT LET
[inaudible]
PROVIDING.
BUT YOU'RE BUT YOU'RE STILL
WITHIN THE DIVISION OF SPEED
THEY ARE AND SO YOU'RE THE
HIERARCHY IS YOU WOULD REPORT TO
SPEAK OUR I PROVIDE A I THINK
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
AGAIN AT THE PURPOSE OF THIS NOT
BY.
SIGHT [inaudible]
HE THAT.
IS PRESENT REALLY IDENTIFY
FRAZIER POINT.
WE SHOULD BE [inaudible] FOR
EXAMPLE [inaudible]
RECENT [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
WITHOUT.
SYSTEMATICALLY LOOKING AT IT
LIKE THAT BROUGHT. ONE WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE IS THE THE LAST TWO
YEARS [inaudible]
NORMAN.
ON HOW DO WE EFFECTIVELY.
I AT AT CREATE [inaudible]
RILED.
I LOOK AT YOU BUT THAT WOULD BE.
ONE WAY.
RIGHT [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I THINK THE IDEA OF A FRAMEWORK.
IN WORKING WITH I'M BACK
REGIONALLY [inaudible]
YEAH -- AT THIS IS WHERE YOU
NEED.
MAYBE WE NEED TO LOOK MORE AT
RIGHT [inaudible] FOR MORE
[inaudible]
THE INTERIM.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE OBVIOUSLY BUT
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHETHER OR NOT.
SO I THINK THAT.
WITH ONE TIME.
THE HELP [inaudible]
EXPERT.
ROUTE WHERE.
WHERE WE LOOK FOR THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE?
AND THE ON GOING BACK. TO THE AT
WORK.
DOWN THAT.
IT THAT.
AND BY BACK [inaudible]
I HAVE [inaudible]
OUR I AM READ I WOULD MISS THE
NAME IN THE RIGHT EXACTLY I'M
NOT SURE WHY I'M NOT EITHER BUT
I HAVE NO IDEA [inaudible]
OUR YOUR ARE YOU [inaudible]
OTHERWISE I WHAT OTHER
[inaudible]
ARE YOU.
ALL IN THE OKAY MIGHT MY
COUNCILMEMBERS AND FELL OFF AND
BRING THE AYE.
BUT CLEARLY MY RESPONSE.
OUR REPORT.
I'VE BEEN THERE.
THE MOST RECENT REPORT
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
SO WE ALSO HAVE BEEN WORKING IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY WAYS
TO BUILD [inaudible]
AND ARE.
YEAH.
SO THAT WE ARE TRANSFERRING --
PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT MORE
[inaudible]
SO.
SO I'M SOME OF IT TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
QUESTION IS OF MY BEING ABLE --
TO MY EXPERTISE IN COMING FROM.
IN THE PARKING AND ANY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AT WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
ON THINGS I FEEL LIKE WITH THE
STRENGTH IN THAT RELATIONSHIP --
AND THEN ALSO OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS THEMSELVES.
WHO ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED --
WELL.
WELL INFORMED ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
AND THEY ADOPT THE WORK PLAN
EVERY.
YEAR AND PRIVATE [inaudible]
WORK ON AS THE AYE IT ISSUE WITH
A CRISIS.
SO EACH YEAR WE DO FOCUS ON
OTHER THINGS AND THIS YEAR WILL
BE WILL BE FIFTEEN ON HELPING
RECOMMENDATION ON OUR FROM
CURRENT.
OF UP OPPOSE THOSE AROUND IT
HOMELESSNESS.
AND BE MADE LONGER IN THE SENSE
THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE
[inaudible]
FORMALLY.
AT THE MALL [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
DIFFERENT.
SOLDIERS BEING TOGETHER NAME
[inaudible]
MANY STUDIES.
WE ARE THE NON FUNCTIONAL.
ALSO WE HAVEN'T.
LOOKED AT THAT WE I MERRILEES.
SPECIFICALLY ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE SERIOUS.
HONEST AND WORK ON IT.
AND THAT'S KIND OF OUR THAT'S
HOW WE NARROW DOWN ARE FOCUSED
IN TERMS OF WHAT.
BUT WE FEEL LIKE WE CAN OFFER
BUT I WAS VERY EL EITHER THAT'S
THE MONEY AND NEVER DONE IT
BUDDY YOUNG OLD DOG -- YOU KNOW.
NO NO NO SIR [inaudible]
WHY NOT [inaudible]
I'M.
IT'S IT IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AM
I I WAS UNAWARE OF BUT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING.
THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT.
MUCH OF OUR ENGAGE STAPLES
ACTUALLY DRIVE ARE A BENDA.
PUTTING.
I'M I'M MORE [inaudible]
PROP. TWENTY A PROBLEM I HAVE.
IS.
IT ARE YOU IT.
MIGHT BE MOVING USING THAT TERM
A LOT.
LATELY BUT OUR I I'M I'M I'M
COMING FROM A MANAGEMENT
STANDPOINT.
I I HAVE TO RUN AN OPERATION AND
I THAT.
I'M NOT READING ANY -- YOUR THAT
WOULD.
AS ME I'M [inaudible]
FINANCIAL BRIEF [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible] TWO RIGHT.
SO.
ARE YOU JUST.
APRIL HEALTH OR YOU.
I DO WE BROUGH.
THE SYSTEM IN OFFICE MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE WE AVOID PROBLEMS THAT ARE
BEING RAISED.
OUR STATUTE REPRESENTS A
IDENTIFIES I WILL BE ABOUT AND
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE ARE YOU
AT UNTIL -- MOST OF IT IS IS
FOCUSED ON PROMOTING WHAT WE ALL
BEST PRACTICES SO I THINK. ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT I HAVE
CHOSEN TO FOCUS ON GROWING THE
AT THE AT THE COUNCIL WITH
RESEARCH THAT IS AS OUR STATUTE
SAYS THAT.
WE SHOULD BASE OUR
RECOMMENDATION FORM ALL THE
STATE ON PAYDAY [inaudible]
SO.
THOSE ARE LIMITED -- TO OPPOSING
GAINES.
I I AND I THINK TOO I JUST TO BE
FAIR -- THE COUNCIL'S BEEN
FUNDED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE AT FUNDING SO THE PLAN.
YES OF THE BAND HAS BEEN THE
SORT OF THE FOCUS HAS BEEN ON ON
PROJECTS THAT RELATE THAT CAN BE
USED WITH THAT SORT OF FUNDING.
THIS FOR THIS PROPOSAL ITSELF IS
ASKING GENERAL FUND WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE COUNCIL TO GET INTO.
AREAS THAT THEY HADN'T
PREVIOUSLY GOTTEN AND AND WHY
DON'T WE JUST ASK FOR MORE MONEY
[inaudible]
BOTTOM LINE [inaudible] TO AN WE
SPECIFICALLY WANTED OF STATE
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO DO MORE WORK LOOKING AT THE
USE OF ROWLEY'S RPN TRAIN AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S A PRIORITY.
LEGISLATURE.
REST AND MOVE THAT SYSTEM AS A
PRIORITY.
ARE MEANT TO MOVE REHABILITATING
THREE AND THREE SO I THINK WE
FELT A LITTLE BIT LIMITED
BECAUSE WE WERE ONLY FUNDED WITH
MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT FELLERS.
WE HAVE A THERE'S THE WHOLE
REALM OF THE WORK THAT WE DO
WITH EDGES.
ATTORNEYS AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS
TO HAVE COME TO US SAYING THAT
THEY ARE.
INTERESTED IN PARTNERING MORE
AND SO THIS GIVES US A LITTLE
BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR US TO
IDENTIFY PROJECT.
THAT.
ARE NOT SPECIFIC TO PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION.
AND ONLY.
A RIGHT I THINK THEY WERE VERY
FOR QUESTIONS IN.
YOU'VE BEEN PUT IN THE HOT SEAT
WE'RE NEITHER.
UNDER MORE LAUGHTER I WORK.
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHEN YOU'RE
COUNSEL WAS DOUBTLESS.
AND WELL I'M SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR
WITH THE STATUTE I THINK
[inaudible]
I'M.
BE CLEAR THE THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN AN ESTABLISHING IT FELT TOO
GREAT NEED AN I'M NOT DESCRIBING
THAT THERE ISN'T A NEED. FOR OUR
UNDERSTANDING MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE COUNSELOR THAT -- MORE
CLEARLY BETTER PROVING BEST
PRACTICE.
I THINK THE THE ISSUE MAY BE
THAT IS THE SCOPE.
OF WORK.
IN A WAY WHEN CONSIDERED AN
UNLIMITED SCOPE OF WORK
[inaudible]
AND DOES. FOR ME ANYWAY DOES.
YOU ADDITIONAL F. B. E. REALLY
ACCOMPLISH IT OR NOT OR WHETHER
WE SHOULD BE APPROACHING THIS.
WAY AND PERHAPS IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE WE INLAND.
THE REAL LOOK AT AS ACTED IN THE
REACHED NUMBER IN WHETHER.
IT FITS YOUR NEEDS NOW.
AND THEN A N. WHETHER THE TYPE
OF FUNCTION.
THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HOUSE.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE LOOKING
AT YOU'RE DOING RESEARCH IN
REVIEWING.
AREAS OF PRACTICE WITHIN CTR
CLEARLY BUT SHOULD IT BE HOUSE
DIRECTLY.
UNDER IN REPORTING.
OUR I THINK THAT MAY BE ANOTHER
LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
A SIMILAR.
TO NOT THAT REFERENCE BUT THERE
WAS A REFERENCE BY MR WIDELY AS
WHETHER.
RULE BOARD SHOULD BE HIRING THE
LAWYERS.
THAT ARE GONNA THEN BE.
I MEAN BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
RIGHT THERE WAS THAT SO THERE'S
ALWAYS THAT -- WHAT'S WHAT IS
OUR PURPOSE FOR AN END TO BE AND
WHAT SITS ATOP THE MALL
REPORTING STRUCTURE. TO ACHIEVE
THAT WHICH YOU KNOW WE MAY YEAH --
I THINK. FOR US WELL THIS WASN'T.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO IS TODAY WAS
JUST OF BY THE BEASTIE BE BEFORE
US.
I THINK FOR THOSE BLESSED WERE.
I'M NOT NUDE YET I HAVEN'T SEEN
REPORTS EITHER JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER.
THE ROLE AND FUNCTION OF THE
COUNCIL AND WHAT AND HOW IT FITS
IN.
WE LOOK AT YOUR CREATION IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE WE'RE VERY
DIFFERENT CDC ARE NOW WE'RE A
VERY DIFFERENT.
THERE'S BEEN MUCH.
ANYWAY SO I THINK IT'S WORTH THE
REST.
I'VE GOT START ON MY LIST FIVE
TIMES GETTING YOU THOSE REPORT
SO WE'RE GOING [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I'M I HOPE
THAT YOU APPRECIATE THAT WE WERE
NOT TRYING TO IN THE AS AND ASK
OF OUR QUESTIONS. ONE IN A WAY
IT WAS MORE IN EDUCATION FOR US
RATHER THAN SO MUCH HEAT NOT FOR
ANY DIRECT CRITICISM OF WHAT
YOU'RE PARTMINER COUNCIL IT'S
BEEN DOING SINCE WERE LESS
FAMILIAR IT'S REALLY MUCH MORE.
RIGHT NOW AND AND I UNDERSTAND.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
I GUESS WE HEARD IT YEAH WE DID
HERE QUALITY.
BUT YOU WERE NO NO NO SENATOR
MORE LIKE IT'S COMPLETELY
LEGITIMATE NIGHT YOUR QUESTIONS
WERE VERY -- ROLE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL NOW GO -- TO THE
BORDER STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
AND WHAT IS BEFORE US IS A
FUNDING FOR STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR LOCAL FOR
CORRECTIONS.
MY COURSE IS ANOTHER ONE SENATOR
MORE LIKE AND I ARE GOING TO BE
LIKE OKAY.
THIS IS I MEAN MOSTLY BECAUSE
WHILE.
REALIGNMENT WAS CLEARLY ENHANCED
AT LEAST WHEN I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE IT WASN'T STARTED IT
WAS START IN OTHER WORDS IT WAS
STARTED PRIOR.
AND EVEN YES HE SEES EXISTENCE
HAS BEEN SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THIS WHOLE.
ROLLER YES CC.
AND COUNTIES IN REALIGNMENT HAS
BEEN -- NOT JUST GROWING OR
MAYBE NOT GROWING IS IT.
IN THE TRANSITION THAT THE STATE
WAS UNDERTAKING BACK IN
[inaudible]
TWENTY ELEVEN THERE WAS.
CLEAR NEED TO ALL RIGHT WE'RE
MAKING A BIG TRANSITION WE
BETTER HAVE SOMEBODY BE
MONITORING -- BUT I THINK SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD
SO FAR.
I'M MOSTLY IN PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
IS FULL ISSUE OF YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHAT'S BEEN OUR OVERSIGHT OR
EVEN YOUR OVERSIGHT EVERYONE.
AND I WILL BE VERY UP FRONT
RIGHT NOW IN THIS IS NOT EXACTLY.
A STEP YES THIS ONE ISSUE AREA
BUT I HAVE A VERY HARD TIME
GETTING ACCURATE DATA. ONE YES.
WHAT IT YOU KNOW HOW?
WHAT IS THE MONEY THAT STATE IS
PROVIDING THE COUNTIES UNDER
REALIGNMENT AND FOR WHAT PURPOSE
AND WHAT'S THE RELATION EITHER
BETWEEN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
HELD?
I'M THEIR HEALTH.
AND WHAT'S YOUR SITE AND WHAT WE
ARE SEEING NOW IS AN INCREASE IN
YEAH.
OF INMATES IN COUNTY JAILS
BURSTING IN A A INCREASE IN.
I'M OLD VARIETY OF ISSUE NOW
PART OF THAT IS WE'VE BUT A LOT
MORE PEOPLE THERE.
IT'S NOT REALLY THE ONLY REASON
BUT IT IS A FACTOR -- AND YOU
KNOW WHETHER THE STATE IS DOING
ACT [inaudible]
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT.
CLEAR TO ME [inaudible]
ON BUT AGAIN YOUR YOUR DAY.
OUT THE BCP FOR STANDARDS IN
TRAINING BUT WE MAY WANT AT SOME
POINT HAVE.
BROADER.
OVERSIGHT OVER STATE OUT -- YES
OF COURSE [inaudible]
EVAN.
I KNOW I KNOW WE CAN FEEL LIKE
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A MAC A LOT OF
MONEY AND THEY FEEL LIKE NO YOU
DID IT.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT BUT THIS IS ON THE
STRAND THEATRE'S IN TRAINING GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
KATIE HOW ARE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE B. SEC SO
JUMPING NARROWLY TO THIS B. C.
P. TODAY WHICH DOES -- PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR CAN OR CORRECTIONS
STC.
I HAVE OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
YVONNE GARNER WHO IS OUR EXPERT
ON THIS TOPIC AND I'LL ASK YOU
TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH AN
OVERVIEW.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
THIS REQUEST IS FOR AN INCREASE
OF SIX POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING FOR TRAINING.
INCLUDING CRITICAL AREAS LIKE
BEHAVIOR HALL CRISIS
INTERVENTION AND DE ESCALATION
COMMON FORM THERE.
GENDER IDENTIFICATION AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND ABUSE.
THE TRAINING IS DESIGNED FOR
CORRECTIONS STAFF EMPLOYED
IMPROVE.
APARTMENTS AND JAILS OPERATED BY
SHERIFF'S OFFICES AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
THE FUNDING REALLY SUPPORTS THE
INCREASE TRAINING DEMANDS
RESULTING FROM MORE COMPLEX
SUPERVISION MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
THAT REQUIRE OFFICERS TO HAVE
MORE AND BETTER.
TRAINING TO SUCCESSFULLY PERFORM
THEIR JOB.
THE FINDING I THINK SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT IT DOES NOT FULLY
COVERED THE COSTS OF LOCAL
CORRECTIONS TRAINING BUT IT'S
REALLY INTENDED TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO CORRECTIONS
AGENCIES IN MEETING.
THE STATE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
AND TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S THE
LARGER [inaudible]
STRATEGY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
I KNOW LA O..
S. M..
I MEANT.
YES MEN OF THE REQUEST GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
AT FIRST I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
RATES OF COMPLIANCE WITH.
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ARE
CURRENTLY VERY HIGH IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ONLY FORTY
SEVEN OUT OF ROUGHLY THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND ELIGIBLE.
OFFICERS AT COMPLETED THE
REQUIRED TRAINING.
I'M.
SORRY EXCUSE ME FAILED TO
COMPLETE EXCUSE ME.
FAILED TO COMPLETE -- STARTING
TO LOSE.
BUDGET.
I HAVE FAILED TO COMPLETE THE
REQUIRED TRAINING -- SO IT
APPEARS THAT HE PROPOSED FUNDING
WOULD HAVE.
LIKELY RELATIVELY LITTLE IMPACT
ON THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF
TRAINING THAT IS RECEIVED.
I'M IN OTHER WORDS WORDS WOULD --
ESSENTIALLY BE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO LOCALS
OR DOING WHAT THEY IS ACTUALLY
ARE ALREADY DOING AND WILL
LIKELY CONTINUE TO BE DOING.
I'M THE BOARD ALSO DOESN'T
COLLECT DATA ON ON I'M WHAT
TYPES OF TRAINING -- OFFICERS
ARE PARTICIPATING IN AS A RISK
AS A PART OF THIS PROGRAM -- SO
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHETHER OR NOT
THE EXISTING TRAINING BEING
PROVIDED AT WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES.
SO WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THAT -- DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT IT WOULD MEANING
CLEAR FACT RAINING.
I'M AN INSIDE DIRECTING THE SEC
TO START COLLECTING DATA ON THE
TYPES OF TRAINING RECEIVED SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
AN ASSASSIN THE FUTURE WHETHER.
THAT TRAINING IS CONSISTENT WITH
ITS GOALS AND THEN POTENTIALLY
BE IN A POSITION TO ALTER.
AND THE PROGRAM SHOULD IT BE AN
CHANGES BEING NECESSARY.
HOWEVER TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO ENSURE THAT
OFFICERS RECEIVE.
AT CERTAIN TYPES OF TRAINING OR
MORE TO MORE TRAINING IN. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT COULD
CREATE A SEPARATE PROGRAM AND
THAT'S MORE TARGETED ONE TIME
GRANT PROGRAM TO ACHIEVE.
GOALS.
IF I UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY
IN EFFECT LA -- SAYING.
NO I'M BEING GLIB NOW BUT YOU
ARE.
THE A YOU'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
AND YOUR PROVIDED THE TRAINING
THAT IT WOULD APPEAR WE'VE
REQUIRED WHY DO YOU NEED ANOTHER
SIX POINT TWO MILLION TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING -- AND SO
THAT [inaudible]
MY NATURAL.
WANT TO COMMENT.
THE COUNTY IS A REALLY
STRUGGLING I THINK RIGHT NOW
WITH ALL OF BEING COMMAND SO I
THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT'S
PAST PERFORMANCE AND IT'S BEEN
GREAT AND LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
WORKING VERY VERY HARD TO ENSURE
ALL THEIR STAFF ARE TRAINED.
BUT THOSE DEMANDS STRESSED KEEP
COMING IN THERE ARE BIGGER AND
THE I AM.
FOCUS RIGHT NOW ON PROVIDING OF
REALLY GOOD BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TRAINING IN THIS REALLY BROAD
UMBRELLA IS GREAT AND THAT'S
LONG AND EXPENSIVE TRAINING.
SO THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE FACED
WITH NOW IN THAT CONTINUING TO
CHALLENGE THEM AND AT THE
REQUEST FOR THIS FUNDING IS TO
HELP.
OFFSET SOME OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR SOME OF THAT MORE AT
AN EXPENSIVE AND LENGTHY --
TRAINING THAT REALLY IS CRITICAL
TO AND THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL JOB
PERFORMANCE AND THE SAFETY OF
THE FACILITIES THAT THEY WORK
AND THE ISSUE IS WHY YOU GAVE US
THAT VERBAL WHEN I READ THE B.
C. P. THERE'S NO.
IT DOESN'T DISTINGUISH WHAT LIKE
THAT THERE'S THIS NEED.
IN A THERE'S YOU KNOW THIS GAP
IN THE TRAINING WE PROVIDE.
AND THUS WE NEED THIS FUNDING.
TO PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THAT IS.
REALLY NOT IN THERE.
YEAH THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT CARDS
OF TRAINING AND ONE IS THE
TRAINING THAT ONE RECEIVES WHEN
THEY ARE FIRST EMPLOYED IN A JOB
AND THAT SORT OF RIGHT TO ME
SOUTH TRAINING IN THESE ARE THE
VERY LENGTHY.
TRAININGS AND WE ARE ACTUALLY
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO TO REQUEST SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DO A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THESE
JOBS TO DETERMINE HOW THEIR JOBS
HAVE CHANGED OVER TIME.
AND WHAT SORT OF NEW ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THEY MIGHT NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY PERFORM THOSE JOBS.
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE
RECENTLY -- REVISED THOSE
ACADEMY CELL TRAINING SO INCLUDE
A LOT OF NEW TRAINING AND IT
INCLUDES A TWENTY FOUR HOUR AND
MODULE IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
AND INSERT GENDER IDENTIFICATION
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND ABUSE I'M SO
LOTS OF NEW TRAINEES BEEN FOLDED
INTO THOSE ACADEMY TRAININGS SO
THAT WAS APPROVED IN JANUARY AND
WE ARE IN A A I'M [inaudible]
SORT OF IT'S A PHASE RIGHT NOW
TRANSITION WHERE WILL BECOME AND
THE FULLY THE NEW REQUIREMENT
I'M A JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO FOLKS ARE GETTING
READY TO DO THAT.
ON THE ANNUAL SIDE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
AND WE DO OUR FULLY PRESCRIPTIVE
IN THE I'M A CATALYST ON MEETING
WE DEFINE ALL OF THE CONTENT
THAT NEEDS TO BE REQUIRED THE
NUMBER OF HOURS YOU KNOW THAT
THE TESTING.
ALL OF THAT ON AT THE ANNUAL
SIDE WE SIMPLY REQUIRING THIS IS
WHERE THE LA WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE CONTENT ISN'T TRACKED WHAT
WE DO REQUIRES A NUMBER OF HOURS
TO BE COMPLETED FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING.
WE DO NOT PRESCRIBE THE CONTENT
OF THOSE HOURS AND THAT IS
BECAUSE THE NEEDS OF THAT
TRAINING VERY IS IT VARIES BY.
BY COUNTY IT VARIES BY THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S GOING TO BE
TRAINED SO WE'VE REALLY LEAVE
THAT TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
EMPLOYING AGENCIES.
AND THAT IS THE PIECE THAT IS IN
THIS PERSPECTIVE AND THAT IS THE
PIECE THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT TIME.
TO PROVIDE A LOT MORE OF THIS
I'M AB ON BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TRAINING THAT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY COURTS GOING TO
PROVIDE A FOUNDATION.
MAYBE YOU ALL JUST NEED -- YEAH
NOT TRYING TO PREDICT THE
OUTCOME OF OUR DELIBERATIONS BUT
IF YOU READ THIS BCP.
I'M SORRY BUT IT SAYS.
B. I'M THERE IS A TRAINING THE
THERE WAS FOUNDED TRAINING GAP
ANALYSIS OR BETTER BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH TRAINING BUT THEN IT SAYS
THE CORE TRAINING NOW INCLUDES
IN IT LISTS MANY ASPECTS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT ARE IN
THE CORE TRAINING.
AND IT DOESN'T INDICATE WHICH
ASPECT OF THIS BEHAVIOR ALL THE
WOULD NEED TO BE ENHANCED IT
SAYS A GREAT AMOUNT OF IT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE INTERVENTIONS
RESOURCES SUICIDE PREVENTION
IT'S ARTS CENTER.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE DATA THAT
SHOWS ONLY FORTY SEVEN OF THE
PEOPLE DIDN'T GET IT YET.
SO.
A AND THEN THE VERY BOTTOM MRS
THIS PER PROPOSAL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO THEY LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN MEET THE STATE
TRAINING STANDARDS FOR THE
CORRECTION WHICH IS THE CORE
TRAINING.
MAJORITY MEETING THEM SO ANYWAY
THAT'S I THINK JUST ONE CLEAR
FINE POINT IS THAT WE DID DO
THIS COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
ENTIRE TRAINING STANDARDS AND
OUR BOARD JUST IN JANUARY.
APPROVED UPDATED NEW AN IMPROVED
AND SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED
TRAINING STANDARDS SELVES THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE OF WHY THIS
RIGHT NOW.
IS IS IN -- VIEW OF THE RECENT
INCREASE IN AND APPROVAL BY THE
BOARD OF OUR TRAINING STANDARDS.
THAT NON COMPLIANCE WAS FOR THE
PRIOR BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED
THESE NEW STANDARDS INCLUDING
THAT EXPANDED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TRAINING.
YOU WEREN'T INTENDING TO ACT ON
IT TODAY BUT NOW WE COULDN'T
ANYWAY GET RIGHT.
BUT AT LEAST YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
MY QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO IT
AND YOU'VE HEARD FROM LA --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE TO MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANNA ADD THAT.
NOT ONLY OTHER ADDITIONAL
STANDARDS THE TRAINING BUT THERE
AS PART OF THIS PROPOSAL IS --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE RECENT CUTS
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDING WITH THE LOCALS CAN.
USE TOWARDS TRAINING SO THE TAPE
INTO CONSIDERATION AS WELL --
WELL THE YOU MIGHT NEED TO
REVISE THIS BC PEAKS IS NOT
OBVIOUS IN IT.
AT ALL.
ISN'T IT AMAZING I ACTUALLY READ
THEM -- ALRIGHT SO.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE SIDE OF ON ROTTEN
SEIU.
ONE THOUSAND WE THINK THAT WHAT
THE LA I WAS SAYING AND ALL
THESE PROGRAMS.
THIS REALLY MAKES SENSE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSUME SOME
OVERSIGHT ON THIS BEFORE WE JUST
KEEP GIVING MONEY. TO THESE
PROGRAMS AND SO WE WOULD.
AND WE WOULD BACK WHAT AT LEAST
ON THIS IN ON THE MANY OTHERS TO
LOOK AT THAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL I'M I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT I I
KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS FAMILIAR
WITH AND THAT -- PROBATION
RECEIVES -- THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CLOSE TO NOT ALL OF OUR TRAINING
THROUGH STC SO IT'S REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL -- AND AND PROBATION
AND SEE POP HOLD TRAINING IN IN
THE HIGHEST REGARD -- AS I THINK
WAS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS IS --
THIS FUNDING HAS DECLINED -- FOR
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS BY
SEVERAL.
MILLION DOLLARS I DO WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE -- OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS FOR LOOKING AT WAYS TO
MOVE ON THE STATE PENALTY FUN TO
BE SEC TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COULD HAVE SOME STABILITY AND
NOT FUNDING AND FOR OVER THE
YEARS ADDING FUNDS.
ON YOU KNOW TO THE FOR THIS
PURPOSE -- BUT THIS RICH IT
REALLY IS CRITICAL FUNDING -- AS
WAS NOTED THE  B. SEC UNDERWENT
COMPREHENSIVE AN ANALYSIS OF
KIND OF THE JOB DUTIES -- IN
LOOKING AT THAT AND I I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THAT IS
REFLECTIVE OF BOTH PROVISIONS
COMMITMENT BUT ALSO THE BSE SEES
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR TRAINING IS CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING.
THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES THAT
IT'S REFLECTIVE OF WHAT OUR
PROFESSION WANTS TO SEE WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES WANT TO SEE AND SO I
SEE PARK REMAINS COMMITTED.
TO AGAIN AND HOPEFULLY -- SEEN
THE INVESTMENT IN THIS FUND --
BUT ALSO DOING SO IN A WAY THAT
THAT IS CAPTURING ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS COMMITTEE.
PROBATION AND OUR PARTNERS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AS WE WE WORK TO
TRAIN OUR OFFICERS THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN FRANK ON THE COMMUNITY
BASED ADVOCATE FOR AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED ME MOTIVATED
INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP REPUBLIC
ADVANCEMENT.
AND TO US YOU KNOW MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENT AND AND TRAINING
GAPS ARE NOT JUST THE LANGUAGE
CHANGE -- IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN UPON HIRING YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO UTILIZE MORE OF
OUR COMMUNITYBASED ASSETS I'M
IN THIS PROCESS AND SO WHICH IS
AS KILEY THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL.
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS RENEE MEN ARE I
WORK AT THE CENTER ON JUVENILE
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS FROM THE LA --
TODAY I REGARDING THE LACK OF
CLARITY ABOUT HOW THIS FUNDING
WOULD MEANINGFULLY I IMPROVE
TRAINING THE PROBLEMS WITH DATA
COLLECTION IN THE S. T. C.
PROGRAM.
I REALLY POINTS TO ISSUES WITH --
THE DATA COLLECTION I IN THE BSE
SEE MORE BROADLY AND ISSUES WITH
ENSURING THE EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF TRAINING.
I WOULD ADD THAT THE PS YOU SEE
IN EXAMINING THE TRAINING
EFFECTIVENESS I NOT ONLY LOOK AT
THE AMOUNT AND THE TYPE OF
TRAINING BUT ALSO HOW IT'S
IMPLEMENTED SO IN PARTICULAR.
I BELIEVE THAT TRAINING IT
SHOULD BE -- INCORPORATING
PRACTICAL METHODS THAT ARE-SCENARIO BASED -- AND THAT
ACTUALLY.
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STAFF.
TO ENGAGE WITH PRACTICAL SKILLS
I REGARDING THESE NEW ELEMENT OR
THAT THAT THE TRAINING REGARDING
AYE GENDER IDENTITY I SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND AND SO FORTH AND I
WOULD ALSO ADD.
THAT ON IN LOOKING AT THE
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF ON
THAT TRAIN PROGRAMS THAT WE ALSO
LOOK AT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROVIDING THE TRAINING AND I
WOULD ASK THAT.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERTISE
SERVING I JUST IS INVOLVED IN
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY I'D
BE ABLE TO SERVE AS EXPERTS IN
THAT.
I THE TRAINING AS WELL THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON TONIC NON FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE LA YOU
ITS RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
I'M FOR THE REASONS LAID OUT BY
THE LA . IT'S ALSO SUPPORT THE
SUGGESTIONS PROPOSED BY MY
PARTNERS BEFORE ME AND ALEJO.
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
LOOKING CLOSELY AT HOW THE BCC
IS CONDUCTING ITS STANDARDS AND
TRAINING DUTIES.
AND ANALYZING AND PERHAPS EVEN
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL MEASURES
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ANY BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS AND PROPOSALS LIKE
TODAY.
THERE BEEN RECENT POWERFUL
EVIDENCE OF THE INFECTED AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE TRAINING
CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY THE B.
ASSISI.
WAS A RECENT LOS ANGELES OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE USE OF
FORCE SPECIFICALLY THE USE OF
CHEMICAL AGENTS.
IN JUVENILE FACILITIES IN LA
COUNTY AND THIS INVESTIGATION
WORK AND COVERED SOME EXTREMELY
DISTURBING PRACTICES INCLUDING
USING CHEMICAL SPRAY IT'S AN
INITIAL INTERMEDIATE RESPONSE TO
NON COMPLIANCE INCLUDING NON
THREATENING NON COMPLIANCE.
I'M A LACK OF KNOWLEDGE OF
APPROPRIATE DECONTAMINATION
PROCEDURES AND THESE THINGS ARE
HIGHLIGHTED IN ONE SPECIFIC
INCIDENT WHERE YOUTH WHO AS.
ENGAGING IN SELF HARMING
BEHAVIOUR WAS ACTUALLY
CHEMICALLY SPRAYED IN THE GROIN
AND BUTTOCKS AND LEFT IN A ROOM
WITH NO RUNNING WATER FOR TWENTY
MINUTES.
THE STAFF THEMSELVES IN THESE
FACILITIES IDENTIFIED INADEQUATE
TRAINING AS THE REASON FOR THE
OVER RELIANCE ON CHEMICAL SPRAY.
THEY SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED THAT
THE COURSES ARE INSUFFICIENT AND
UNREALISTIC.
HE SAID THAT IMPROVEMENTS ARE
NEEDED IN THE CONTENT OF THE
TRAINING AND ALSO THE METHODS
FOR DELIVERY OF THE TRAINING.
AND I SAY ALL THIS TO APPRECIATE
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE LA YO'S.
AN EFFORT TO LOOK CLOSELY AT
WHAT WOULD ACTUALLY EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVE TRAINING.
TIME AND FOR ANY FURTHER
ANALYSIS AT THIS COMMITTEE OR
THE LA -- OR ANYONE ELSE CAM
DOCKS I WOULD ENCOURAGED
ANALYSIS TO ALSO INCLUDE
EXAMINATIONS OF OTHER DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE BE A CC FOR EXAMPLE
THE BILL STILL THE STANDARDS AND
TRAINING.
AND OPERATIONS DIVISION WHICH IS
IN CHARGE OF INSPECTING AND
MONITORING FACILITIES.
WITH PROPER INSPECTIONS THAT
COULD HAVE HELPED IDENTIFY THE
TRAINING SHORTCOMINGS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN LA COUNTY AND PROSPER
AND A LOT OF COST THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S IN ORDER
THESE AGAIN HA COMMITTEE
ORGANIZE AND ALSO A CO FOUNDER
OF AN ORGANIZATION CALLED SELF
AWARENESS AND RECOVERY.
IT OFTEN AND I WHO DID THIRTY
NINE YEARS FOR WRONGFUL
CONVICTION.
CO FOUNDED AS A WAY TO ADDRESS
TRAUMA THAT WASN'T BEING
ADDRESSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WAS JUST
VERY BASIC.
STANDARD YOU KNOW ROUTINES --
YOU KNOW THERE'S A HARD PERSONAL
FOLDERS THERE'S NO.
NEED TO REALLY WORK AS WE JUST
NUMBERS WERE JUST DATA YOU KNOW
AND SO -- I'VE SEEN HOW YOU KNOW
THEY WERE TO ME TO THE TRAIN IS
A LOT GOES DOWN IT THIS IN OUR
STAFF THE STAFF OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO GO IN TRAINING
COME BACK.
THIS ALL JUST STANDARD YOU KNOW
OLD SCHOOL TRADITIONAL COOKIE
CUTTER TRAINING.
THAT IS NOT HAVING MUCH OF AN
IMPACT THE I I WANNA PROPOSAL OF
THE FOUR I WANT TO REJECT.
THIS PROPOSAL BUT I WANT TO
PROPOSE. TO TO TO FOR THE HAVE A
DISCUSSION AROUND THIS SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED THE PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS TO BE ON
THE RECEIVING END.
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE TRAINING SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE A MORE
COLLECTIVE UP PERSPECTIVE AND
ALSO.
HIGHER HIGHER COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE A PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DONE THEIR INTERNAL WORK
PEOPLE WHO WERE CONSIDERED
MURDERS THAT WILL NEVER CHANGE
THEIR LIVES GANG MEMBERS BUT YET
WE WERE ABLE TO OURSELVES AS
PEERS. TO FIND THE CAUSATIVE
FACTORS OF OUR CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
SOMETHING THAT THE ORDER
REQUIRES FOR US TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO HE WILL MAKE THE
PROFOUND CHANGES THAT WE'VE MADE
THAT HAVE ALLOWED US TO COME
HOME.
AND ALLOW THE GOVERNOR TO SIGN
OFF AND AND AND ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
PAROLE.
SO IF WE HAD TRANSIT MADE
CHANGES IN PEOPLE'S LIFE
INTERNALLY YOU KNOW TO START OF
JUSTICE PRACTICES PROMOTION
INTELLIGENCE -- IN OUR MOTION
MODIFICATION CONCEPTS AND IT
REALLY BECOMING AWARE AND AND
AND I ARE HEALING THE TRAUMA.
THAT THAT THE DEALERS ESPECIALLY
WITH OUR PRISON GUARDS ARE
PRISON GUARDS HAVE A HIGH LEVEL
OF THOMAS NOT ADDRESS IS NOT
EVEN BEING TALKED ABOUT THEY
HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF DIVORCE THEY
HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
OTHER USING DRUGS AND ALCOHOL
AND YOU KNOW EVEN THOUGH IT'S
NOT REALLY A PUBLIC RECORD ALL
THAT STUFF BUT BUT THEY THEY
HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF THOMAS OF WE
HAVE IN THIS OFFICE --
INTERTWINED WITH FORCE TO
REHABILITATION THE ARE YOU NEED
TO HAVE THE HEALING THAT
INTERNAL HEALING THAT THE
STANDARDIZED THESE ARE THE
GUIDELINES IS ABOUT SOME REALLY
INTERNAL HEALING DIAL ALSO HINTS
VOCAL.
OF TALKING WHAT IT IS TO BE A
PRISON GUARD AND THE PRESSURES
THAT THEY GO TO EVERY DAY AND
ALLOW ENOUGH SPACE WILL EXPLORE
AND HE'LL OF TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES SO THEY CAN BE MORE
EFFECTIVE PRISON GUARDS.
REALLY IMPLEMENT THE
REHABILITATION AT THE KERRY
UNDERSHIRTS TO TO SERVICE AND
AND AND REALLY HELP OUR PEOPLE
BECOME HEALTHY CITIZENS TO COME
BACK INTO THIS COMMUNITY.
AND CONTRIBUTE SO IF YOU GUYS
OPEN TO THAT -- I'M MORE THAN
OPEN TO TO TO BRING THE TEAM IS
SO WE CAN EXPLORE THOSE
POSSIBILITIES.
I INTO THEN IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
WE KEEP GOING TO THE SAME.
SAME SPENDING.
HAVE AN IMPACT.
AB SAWYER WAS AT A HEARING LAST
TIME WHERE THEY DID THE RESEARCH
ON ON THESE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT SOME OF THE
DATA WAS UPDATED.
TO TWO THOUSAND ONE SO THERE'S
REALLY WE REALLY WE NEED NEED TO
TO LOOK AT WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON IN LUCKILY THERE'S A LOT OF
US ARE FINALLY COMING HOME IN A
REALLY GOING RESOURCE FOR
EDUCATE OURSELVES.
WOULD BE PROACTIVE IN WE'RE NOT
OUT HERE TRYING -- TO BASICALLY.
YOU KNOW TO MULLIN WAS A
PERSONAL BODIES PARADE BUT WE
ARE HERE TO PROPOSE THAT THAT WE
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AND THINK
OF SOME PROGRESSIVE PROACTIVE
APPROACH IS TO REALLY IMPLEMENT
WILL REHABILITATION LOOKS LIKE.
REALLY -- IMPLEMENT WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE HEALTHY STAFF
MEMBERS AND PRISON GUARDS THAT
THEY ARE TREATING THE ARE ARE
PEOPLE WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY
WHEN IT COMES TO INCARCERATIONS
SO THEY COULD COME OUT IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
ENTRY PEOPLE RESPECT TO TO THINK
AND DIGNITY BECAUSE IF YOU TELL
LIKE MONSTERS YOU GO TO CREATE A
US A PRESS MONSTER WITH
SUPPRESSED EMOTIONS AND PHAM WAS.
FROM HIS UPBRINGINGS ALL WENT
THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BRING THAT INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
AFTER DOING EIGHTEEN YEARS I
CAN'T MY WITH A LOT OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES YOU KNOW I I SO
FOR A LITTLE BIT MANIC
DEPRESSION ANXIETY FROM ALL THE
PRESSURES.
OF OF THE SYSTEM RIGHT A LOT OF
IT CAME FROM OUR GUARD TONIGHT
AND RATHER THAN LOOKING IN
JUDGING IN HAITI.
I ALWAYS TOLD MYSELF WHEN I GET
A ONE OF MY INTENTIONS IS TO
PROPOSE SETTING CIRCLES FOR THE
FOR THE POLICE OFFICE BECAUSE
THEY GOT A LOT OF HURT.
NOBODY'S ADDRESSING THAT IN
WHICH PICKING UP TO HAVE THESE
LITTLE BASIC TRAINING.
BUT A AND AND BUT NOTHING
CHANGES ARE SO HARD TO SUPPOSED
TO BROKE.
SO I REALLY WANNA ARE YOU GUYS
TO CONSIDER THAT AND AND MAYBE
PULL SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE
WITH WITH WITH THE COMMUNITY --
COLLECTIVE AND AND AND THE
PROPOSAL.
THANK.
I AM A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FRANKIE WAS MINE I'M A AN
ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW.
AND ALSO ABOUT RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND -- I I'D LIKE TO ECHO
WHAT A LOT OF WHICH MEANS -- I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
DIFFICULT JOB OF THE B. AS HE
HAS BEEN IN.
YOU KNOW -- SUPPORTING SYSTEM
THAT OFTENTIMES ARE SET UP TO
SUCCEED TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
DESIGNED TO DO WHICH IS TO HELP
KIDS IN CONFLICT WITH THE LAW
THAT ARE.
EXPERIENCING CRISES IN THEIR
LIVES.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON WHETHER OR NOT YOU
KNOW TO FUND THIS TRAINING
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE ISSUE I DO THINK THAT
TRAINING IS IMPORTANT BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TRAINING.
IS THAT GONNA FIX EVERYTHING --
I THINK THAT.
MORE ATTENTION AND EFFORT AND
AND AND INVESTORS NEED TO BE
PLACED IN OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
BECAUSE I'M ALSO FOREMAN
INCARCERATED AND ONE THING THAT
I KNOW IS THAT -- AS FROM YOU
KNOW THE STATE THE SYSTEMS FAR
AS THEY'RE CONCERNED.
ACCOUNTABILITY OFTENTIMES A ONE
WAY STREET WHERE WE HOLD
CHILDREN AND THE POWER IS
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THE POWERFUL.
GUARDS IN AND AND THE UNIONS
AREN'T HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE INVESTORS
PLACED ON I KNOW HOLDING THE D..
THE ENFORCERS ACCOUNTABLE AND
AND AND ONE FORCE IN IN THAT
REGARD AND SO YOU KNOW I WELL I
DO TING TRAINING IS IMPORTANT.
I THINK THAT GREATER INVESTMENTS
TO TO BE.
PLACED ON ON HIRING PRACTICES --
YOU KNOW -- OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTED
EITHER BE SEC OR ARE IN FINE SIR
LA -- WANT ME.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING IN
THESE ITEMS WILL COME BACK
OBVIOUSLY -- AND FREE SHADE
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION THANK
YOU.
AND WE WILL NOW CONCLUDE.
HE OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY